Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Das war's für heute.
So, bin ich am Start.
Max, was ist mit deiner Stimme los? Bist du jetzt eine Animefrau?
Was assumest du hier einfach für Dinge? Heutzutage muss man da ja aufpassen.
Vielleicht war ich schon immer eine Animefrau. Kann ja alles sein.
Bin ich ein hortes Grill.
Kaffee, ich trinke keinen Kaffee.
Kaffee erinnert mich immer zu sehr an Java. Kann ich keinen Kaffee trinken.
Wir brauchen noch einen Anti-Java-Emote, einfach weil es geht.
Ist da.
Das sieht schon fast nach dem Java-Icon aus.
Das Problem ist, die Auflösung ist so schlecht.
Die Auflösung ist bei beiden schlecht.
Aber ich meine, gute sind ja auch noch im Outstar.
Das könnte fast als Animation durchgehen.
Ja, man erkennt es, ich wollte es verschieben.
Das Frühstückste in der Regel, eigentlich frühstücke ich nur zwei Brötchen und auch ohne, dass da irgendwie großartig, also ich mache keine Butter drauf, ich mache da irgendwie keinen Frischkäse oder sonst was drauf.
Ich mache einfach immer nur zwei, ich nehme zwei Scheiben Käse.
Jetzt habe ich mich auf meinen Mute-Knopf gehauen gerade. Ich nehme immer nur zwei Scheiben Käse, mache die aus Brötchen drauf und fertig.
Das reicht.
Muss ich mal ein Chrome updaten?
Irgendwie findet er keine Updates mehr, was ist da los?
Die werden hier einfach nicht geupdatet drin.
Das ist ein ganz schöner Fail.
Sind die nicht geupdatet?
Komisch.
Guck mal, das ist transparent das Bild, das scheint hier unten durch, seht ihr das?
Voll next level.
Kein Tipp.
Huge, huge Fock.
Richtig Monka-Seption.
Ich habe nur deine Cod-Videos geschaut.
Das war schon ein ganz schönes Stück her.
Cod 2019.
Das wäre ja gut, wenn es mal wieder einen Game gäbe.
Ach, ich weiß mit welchem Video wir anfangen.
Wie gesagt, heute ist ja Aufwachs-Stream, also wir gucken heute ein bisschen Videos und gucken uns ein paar Sachen an.
Und was weiß ich, ich weiß mit was wir anfangen.
Ich habe nämlich ein Video gefunden.
Jetzt müssen wir auch einen Stream gucken.
Mal gucken wie lange man den Kram noch kennt.
Wahrscheinlich dürfte ich ab da des Black Ops 2, das habe ich noch gespielt, ab da irgendwie aufgehört haben zu spielen.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an, zum Aufwachen.
So, hat vier Dings.
Ambush? Nee, Moment.
Overcron ist das, ne?
Das ist ein Game, wo man es schon merken konnte.
Ok, da sind die Cod-Kluge unterwegs.
Ok, wenn das live erspielt ist, dann spielt er das wahrscheinlich auf der 360 oder so.
Oder ist das backwards compatibility?
Wenn man das so aussprechen könnte, ne?
Ah, backwards compatibility.
Ich könnte das sogar mal wieder auf meiner Xbox One spielen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich war mit meiner Xbox One, die steht hier seit 2013 einfach nur rum.
Die steht einfach nur rum seit 2013, total beknackt, ne?
Da bei dem Controller liegen, steht extra in der Mitte, ganz fett.
Day 1, 2013.
Benutzt wurde das Ding, keine Ahnung, 5 Stunden oder so.
So gut wie nix.
Was ein bisschen doof ist am Xbox One Controller,
wo ich das Ding gerade in der Hand habe,
erstens finde ich sind die, wie nennt man das, diese Träger hinten,
diese Schultertasten da, diese analogen Schultertasten,
die sind so komisch flach an der Seite, das gefällt mir nicht.
Aber ok, kann man mitleben.
Was ich persönlich ein bisschen doof finde am Xbox One Controller,
ist, dass der nicht mehr so wund in der Mitte ist wie der 360 Controller.
Also unten dort, wo das Ladekabel dran kommt, da wo man die Hände dran hat,
ich zeige euch das.
Guckt euch mal das da an, im Vergleich mit dem da.
Sieht man sofort, dass das hier unten eckiger ist als da, oder?
Da ist viel runder als da.
Hier so eckig.
Und warum das für mich doof ist, immer wenn ich mich aufrege beim Spielen an der Xbox,
zumindest war das bei der 360 so, und ich meine bei der 360 habe ich mit Fabian viel Cod gespielt,
da hat man sich öfters mal aufgeregt, ich meine ihr kennt das ja vielleicht noch.
Da habe ich immer meinen Controller genommen, habe den hier an der Seite mit der rechten Hand genommen
und habe damit gegen meine linke Hand gehauen, wenn ich mich aufgeregt habe.
So, Fabian hat auch immer gesagt, irgendwie dreht er wieder durch, jetzt schlägt er irgendwie mit seinem Controller auf sich.
Das war halt so zum Abreakieren, wenn du dich aufgeregt hast, ne?
Du konntest, du keine Einung, manche Leute haben den Controller in den Fernseher geschmissen,
manche Leute haben die Konsolen aus dem Fenster geworfen, ich habe halt meinen Controller genommen und so gegen die Hand gehauen.
Das Problem ist, wenn der Controller rund ist, kannst du das machen.
Wenn der Controller stabiler ist, ich habe auch Gefühl, dass der One Controller ein härteres aus härterer Material ist,
und du haust genau mit dieser Ecke gegen deine Hand, das machst du genau 5-6 Mal, dann tut dir die Hand weh.
Ich weiß, das sind die übelsten First World Problems, aber es ist schon ein Unterschied.
Was ich auch ein bisschen blöd finde am Xbox One Controller, oder was heißt blöd, eigentlich ist es besser,
aber was mir am Anfang überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, sind die Sticks, die sind größer am 360 Controller,
und ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das macht, spielt ihr mit euren Daumenspitzen auf dem Controller oder mit der Unterseite vom Daumen?
Ich spiele quasi mit der Unterseite vom Daumen, also mit der Unterseite vorne vom Daumen spiele ich.
Das Problem ist, dass mir es ganz zugute kommt, wenn die Auflage vom Controller ein bisschen breiter ist,
weil so habe ich permanent das Problem, dass ich mit dem Daumen den Stick, wenn ich den ganz nach links drücke, drücke ich den mit der Seite, mit dem Rand zur Seite,
und das Problem hat es bei dem 360 Controller nicht, allerdings muss man sagen, sind die Sticks vom Xbox One Controller an sich viel nicer.
Wie spielt man denn mit Spitzen? Keine Ahnung, Grills machen das, guckt euch mal Gaming Grill Videos an oder so,
wenn die einen Controller in der Hand haben, die spielen das schon halb mit den Fingernägeln.
So um so sehr mit den Daumenspitzen wird das da gespielt.
Jetzt hat natürlich jemand, also einer, der ernsthaft spielt, wird das wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen, aber man sieht das doch recht oft.
Einfach PC spielen, ja. Hast du recht, im Prinzip mache ich das jetzt ja auch, ne? Eigentlich mache ich das jetzt ja auch.
Ne, aber ich habe jetzt eigentlich draufgekommen. Gucken wir uns jetzt mal das Video weiter an.
Was sind das eigentlich für Bots gegen die, die da spielen, Alter? Alles Level 1er.
Alter, was für Bots, perfekt. Vor allem die M16 war in dem Teil auch noch richtig nice, ne? Wenn du da gut getroffen hast, hast du alle One-Shotted, also drei Burst-Shotted.
Das war, was ich an Code 4 persönlich wirklich cool fand, so im Nachhinein betrachtet, das war ja so der Einstieg in diese moderne Call of Duty-Ära.
Also was ich ja dran geil fand, es ist ähnlich wie damals in Bad Company 1. Bad Company 1 haben wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle gespielt, weil Bad Company 1 war ja Konsolen-Exklusiv.
Was ich daran halt echt nice fand, ist, es war aus der heutigen Sicht reduziert. Für die damalige Zeit war da richtig viel dabei, ja, aber es war weder mit Killstreaks übertrieben, es war noch mit Waffen übertrieben.
Also du hattest dort Waffen drin, weil sie Unterschiede hatten. Du hattest in Code nicht eine Waffe, die gleich der anderen war im Endeffekt, ja.
Du hattest alle mögliche Sachen, du hattest eine M16, du hattest eine M4, äh, ne, ne, ne, M14 war das, du hattest eine AK-74, du hattest eine AK-74, das waren alles komplett unterschiedliche Waffen, die sich auch im Handling komplett unterschiedlich angefühlt.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Waffen es mittlerweile in Black Ops 4 gibt. Ich hab jetzt ja gelesen, in Black Ops 4 gibt es jetzt ja, ähm,
Pay to Win, ähm, Ballistic Knife gibt es da jetzt. Also man kann sich wohl irgendwie, das Ballistic Knife gibt es wohl irgendwie nur in Boxen oder so, irgendwie, ich befolge das nicht so richtig.
Ähm, und zumindest ist das nicht einfach so ein Ballistic Knife in, in, in, mal angucken, ob es irgendwie davon geht.
Das ist jetzt in Black Ops 4 das richtig befeuert. Ja, jetzt reacten sie mal wieder, jetzt wird man wieder krass reactet und rumgeschrien. Zumindest das Ballistic Knife ist irgendwie, äh, Dual-Wheeled in, in Black Ops 4, habe ich gesehen.
Also sprich, da hast du einen, du hast einen Doppel-One-Shot-Ballistic Knife dabei und das kriegst du wohl irgendwie nur aus Supply Drops, wo du dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, 50 Millionen Cut Points oder so ausgeben musst.
Als hälst du eigentlich schon einen neuen Teil. Äh, haben wir uns letzte Woche, letzte Woche Sonntag hier angeguckt. Ähm, ich fand also insgesamt, fand ich ja das ganz okay aus, das Problem ist, wenn ich mir jetzt angucke, was sie da aus Black Ops 4 gemacht haben, so nach dem Motto, die richtet jetzt, jetzt drehen wir richtig, ähm, die Microtransaction-Lootboxen und Supply Drop-Geschichte auf, quasi nachdem das Game Refuse gekriegt hat, nachdem das Game schon ein bisschen alt ist.
Am Anfang erzählen wir so nach dem, ach nee, hier kein Pay-To-Win, alles Kosmetik, blablabla und ein halbes Jahr nach Release dreht man nicht nur ein bisschen auf, wie am Anfang, sondern so richtig, ist das eigentlich für mich ein Grund auch zu sagen, ich kauf mir keinen Modern Warfare.
Weil, was hat man denn davon, wenn das Game rauskommt? Und mal angenommen, das Game fühlt sich gut an und mal angenommen, das Game ist auch nice.
Und man sagt, ey, das ist mal wieder ein Game, was man länger spielen kann, das ist mal wieder ein Game, wo man sich so richtig, was man auch mal lernen kann, wo man halt mal ein bisschen Mühe beigeben kann.
Und dann, äh, spielt man 1-2 Monate, ist ganz gut, wunderbar und dann wird das Game komplett zerstört durch irgendwelche Microtransaction-Lootboxen.
Da hat man eigentlich keinen Bock drauf, ne?
Wer ist auch noch müde? Würde man sagen, wahrscheinlich der halbe Streben ist noch müde.
Also das sind die übelsten Bots, die jeder da spielt. Aber gut, ich mein, wer spielt auch noch COD4 heute, ne?
Der spielt auch noch COD4. Wahrscheinlich die Typen, die irgendwo sich für 2,50 Euro Gebrauch beim GameStop das Game gekauft haben und denken, oh geil, kann ich auf meiner Xbox One jetzt spielen.
Ähm, und er hat es halt eindeutig schon mal gespielt, ne?
Ja, Sniper aufheben, jetzt wird erstmal alles weggequickscoped.
Ich habe hier absichtlich ein bisschen leise gemacht, weil ich mein, er sagt, glaube ich, gerade nichts anderes, nicht sinnvolles.
Videos übrigens, wir wollen uns ja nicht hier so allzu sehr mit fremden Fehlern schrubben.
Ähm, ich guck mir das aber eigentlich bloß an, dass man man die letzten paar Call of Duty-Games so im Zeitraff, was ich nochmal angucken kann, weggesniped, aber, äh...
Konntest du auf den Maps auch teilweise richtig coole Tricks machen, wie ihr auf das, was heißt Tricks in Anführungsstrichen, auf das Dach und sowas, ähm, was die Noobs nie kapiert haben.
Alter, was sind, das sind ja die, oh, okay, die übelste COD4 Hit Detection live, ja, oder, oder, soll man so besser gesagt, P2P-Housing live.
Ähm, das sind halt, das sind halt übelste Bots.
42, neun, okay, 42, neun im normalen TDM ist ein Score, den kriegst du nie. Nie kriegst du den, es sei denn, es sind die abgrundtiefsten Bots als Gegner aller Zeiten.
Weil ich mein, wie schafft man allen Ernstes 0 zu 10? Wie geht das überhaupt den COD? Wie kriegt man 0 zu 10?
Das reicht ja schon, wenn du einfach spawnst mit nem Noobtube und zehnmal in die Richtung von nem Gegner schießt. Einmal wirst du schon killen damit.
Ja.
Oh, jetzt kriegt er, jetzt wird er geschneibt. Oh, das ist COD5. Und ausgerechnet auch noch in der kack COD5 Map.
Indem man wieder Ultraskeller spielt. Hatste nicht sogar deren Kill gekriegt?
Echt.
Das war auch noch recht reduziert COD5.
Nein, nein, nein, ich mein mit Bots nicht Bots. Ich mein mit Bots echte Spieler, in dem Fall die so spielen wie Bots. Das waren schon echte Spieler.
Das war halt schlecht. Also was ich jetzt erstmal machen würde ist, MP40 Juggernaut. Erstmal MP40 Juggernaut auspacken.
Wenn ich heute wieder COD5 spielen würde, erstmal MP40 Juggernaut an.
Jawoll, so geht das. MP40 Juggernaut in your face.
Das war so eine absolut krasse OP Kombination MP40 Juggernaut. Ich weiß gar nicht ob er Juggernaut an hat.
Wenn er Stopping Power an hat, ist es noch, killt er die Leute. Das war so OP.
Aber ich persönlich ja lieber in COD5 habe ich Thompson mit Extended Max gespielt.
Und das war nervig in COD4. Diese Memen, das war ätzend.
Okay, das sind auch wieder die übelsten Bots am Start. Aber ohne Scheiß Leute, nur so.
Ja da fehlen COD1, 2, 3. Er hat auch am Anfang gesagt. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Übel Side Track Song.
Die checken wieder gar nichts. Aber nur so macht COD richtig Bock, wenn du Noobs zerstören kannst.
Ansonsten ist das okay. Das Problem ist, woran meiner Meinung nach COD so ein bisschen krankt,
nicht wirklich als Competitive Spiel. Weil wenn du das wirklich competitive spielst, dann lass ich mir das gefallen.
Aber wo COD ein bisschen krankt, ist Public Tryhard. Das kannst du in anderen Games machen.
Weil du da in gewisser Weise das Spiel, wenn du gut bist, in soweit beeinflussen kannst, dass dir halt nicht laufen und irgendein Bullshit passiert.
Bei COD ist es so, es macht unglaublich Bock, Noobs zu zerstören, die nichts auf die Reihe kriegen.
Was meint ihr, warum diese ganzen 40-0-sonst-was-Gameplays immer so beliebt sind oder beliebt waren?
Das Problem ist, COD macht wenig Spaß, wenn deine Gegner halbwegs kompetent sind.
Und das liegt daran, nicht weil die Gegner halbwegs kompetent sind.
Auch in den älteren Teilen hast du Obernoobs gebraucht, die du komplett zerstören konntest.
Dann hat es mega Bock gemacht. Wenn du aber ein paar Tryhard-Gegner hattest, war das Problem.
Du hast halt selber nie eine wirklich gute Runde gehabt, weil es so viel Random Mist einfach immer gegeben hat, dass dich gekillt hat, wo du auch nichts dagegen machen kannst.
Und ich habe mir vom Thunder letztens wieder ein Black Ops 4 Video angeguckt und habe festgestellt, wie viel unglaublicher Bullshit da drin ist.
Wie gesagt, geht ja schon los mit Dual-Wheeled-Ballistic-Knives. Der ist auf die Idee gekommen, dass Dual-Wheeled-Ballistic-Knives eine gute Idee sind.
Die es natürlich nur aus Supply-Drops gibt, die du kaufen musst.
Ah, 432, das ist schon wahr. Hätte er mal MP40 Juggernaut gespielt, ne?
MW2!
Ich finde immer noch, dass mein MW2 ein bisschen schnell gestorben ist.
Auch wenn es jetzt nicht so aussieht, aber in MW2 hast du das Gefühl gehabt, du wurdest angehustet manchmal und bist umgekippt.
Oh, Juggernaut. Da ging es los. Das war der Anfang vom Ende, was Random Bullshit und Noobs weniger frustrierend angeht.
Guckt es euch an. Das da.
Das war mit der Anfang vom Ende, dass man so eine Scheiße eingebaut hat.
Ja, Ghosts waren noch schlimmer vom aushalten.
Oh, die kriegen aufs Maul. Wobei das Flugzeug so viel trifft da gar nicht.
Okay, man sieht schon mal, dass es nicht die Ultra-Bobs sind als Gegner. Die können immerhin den Harrier kaputt machen.
Weil die richtig guten Runden in MW2, also die Nuke-Runden, die hat es in MW2 ja nur, wenn du Harrier, Chopper, Gunner und sowas hattest am Stück.
Chopper, Gunner? War das in MW2? Ja, doch, MW2. AC-130 war auch in MW2. Da konntest du dir aussuchen, was du nimmst.
Harrier, Chopper, Nuke. Genau, so war das. Vielleicht noch davor.
Ach Quatsch, Nuke war ja ein fester Kill-Sweep in MW2. Du musstest ja wirklich die Nuke ausrüsten. Das hat dir einfach gereicht mit 25 Kills.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Noob-Splashen ohne Ende. Und im Zweifelsfall 5 Games erst mal quitten, bis man in den ordentlichen Noob-Lobby drin ist.
Chopper, Gunner, ready for deployment. Jawoll.
Go right under here, we don't have a lot of time.
Chopper, Gunner. Man kann es ja auch in easy abschießen, deswegen war die AC-130 eigentlich viel besser.
Jetzt schreckt.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, das ist ein Game von der 360.
Das ist ein ziemlich altes 360-Game, aber es sieht im Vergleich zu den etwas neueren Call of Duty gar nicht so viel schlechter aus.
Da hat sich in den letzten Jahren nicht viel getan. Wobei man sagen muss, das neue Modern Warfare sieht für CoD-Verhältnisse wirklich gut aus.
Mal gucken, wie es aussieht, wenn es rauskommt. Ja, warten wir es mal ab.
Das stimmt, hast du recht. Der Chopper ist vor das Terminal geflogen. Das stimmt. Das kommt ein bisschen auf die Map an.
Wenn du Wasteland gespielt hast, war die AC-130 viel nicer. Ja, das kommt ein bisschen auf die Map an.
Allerdings, dafür hast du bei der AC-130 dieses 120mm Geschütz, wo du halt einfach nur in die Nähe schießen musstest. Das war alles down.
Der muss messern. Ich hoffe, er macht die Messer Nuke. Kennt ihr noch die Messer Nuke? Du musst, wenn die Nuke dich killt, musst du messern.
Sonst geht es nicht. Sonst ist das nicht legit.
Messern? Messern? Messern?
Noob. Nicht gemessert bei der Nuke.
Das geht nicht. Oh, Black Ops 1, beste.
Ist eigentlich immer noch mein Lieblings-Cod.
Ups.
Was ich auch cool fand, teilweise das Voice-Acting in MW2 und Black Ops 1, vor allem in MW2, da hat es ja die Typen, die übelst rumgeschrien haben.
Das haben sie in den neueren Teilen, glaube ich, gar nicht. Wenn einer da irgendwie rumschreit, AC-130 und Bufflet.
Oh, das hast du irgendwie in anderen Teilen gar nicht.
Sie waren da teilweise voll am eskalieren.
Okay, bin wach.
Was ist das eigentlich? AK-74U? Was hat er? Griff? Griff? Sieht man sonst irgendwas? Hat man die Klasse gesehen in ihrer Spiel?
Moment, ich würde noch mal kurz gucken. Klasse? Was spielt er?
Nein, das spielt er nicht.
Das spielt er doch gar nicht.
Das ist die falsche Klasse, die er gezeigt hat.
Es hatte jedes Cod so ein bisschen irgendwelche bekannten Voice-Samples.
Tango Sucker. Was übrigens gar nicht Tango Sucker hieß, sondern das war halt irgendein arabisches Wort, was sich wie Tango Sucker angehört hat.
Oder was hat man sonst noch? Wo war das? Hayabina? War das Black Ops 2 oder war das Black Ops 3?
Das ist ja geil.
Ja stimmt, Extended Magdots hat die Position.
Ich glaube das Video ist insofern immer ein bisschen gefaked, aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das die erste Runde ist, die er uns zeigt.
Es ist die erste Runde, die er uns zeigt, weil man muss schon sagen, jetzt einfach mal wieder seit ein paar Jahren ein Spiel anmachen und dann instant irgendwie die 40er Kills...
Okay, das waren übelste Bots in God 4. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, er wird einfach ein paar Spiele gespielt haben und das Beste genommen haben.
Ist auch nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Ja, er hat es bei MW2 gesagt, aber das würde ich mal gar nicht so eng sehen. Er hat es bei MW2 gesagt, als erstes Gameplay habe ich Nuke gekriegt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das glaube, aber das ist eigentlich auch nicht so.
Ich hätte ja mal übelst Bock, um meine Xbox One zu entstauben und mal wieder irgendwie God 4 oder Black Ops 1 rein zu machen.
Aber wahrscheinlich halte ich das eh nicht lang durch, weil ich bin total außer Übung, was Controllern angeht.
Da ist die Moab. Super Krogi.
P2P Hosting, Beste!
Stimmt, P2P Hosting, wo du dann ins Dashboard gequittet hast und das Ding Hostmigration nicht mal funktioniert hat.
Das ist MW3.
Äh, das ist MW3? Das ist wie MW2.
MW3? Ja, das ist MW3.
Oh, das ist die OP. Das ist eine der größten OP-Waffen überhaupt.
Du konntest mit dem Ding, mit dieser Wasserpistole, du konntest Extended Max Rapid Fire, wenn du das dran gemacht hast, weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Extended Maps gebraucht hat.
Du hast die Leute Hüft-Sprayed über die komplette Map.
Das Ding ist übertrieben OP gewesen.
Das war die erste und glaube einzige Goldwaffe, die ich in dem Game hatte, einfach weil ich fast nichts anderes gespielt habe am Anfang, weil das Ding so OP gewesen ist.
Ist hier nicht Bison? Ich weiß es nicht, aber das Ding, das war übertrieben OP.
Oh, Panic Knife. War noch nicht mal Panic Knife.
Weckt. Ist in der Macht schon mal richtig hier. Schön mit Silencer durch die Gegner gestellt und dann geht alles weg. Assassin Pro. War das noch mal.
Was war Assassin noch mal, das man nicht gesehen wird aus dem UAV?
Ach, da gab es ja noch diese komischen Hacker-Lobbies, die die Leute gesettet haben.
Was war denn das? Was zum Teufel war das für ein Gegner?
Moab? Wo ist die Moab?
Ich glaube, danach habe ich aufgehört viel CoD zu spielen. Black Ops 2 habe ich noch gespielt. Das ist Havana, oder?
Nee, das ist nicht Havana. Havana war Black Ops 1. Wie hieß die Map? Ich weiß es nicht. Die Map gibt es auch in Black Ops 4, kann das sein?
Nice. Da gab es schon relativ viel Bullshit, was ich killen konnte.
Wir haben wieder die ganzen Bots von hinten weg gesprayt. Der Q-Chat hat Plan, ja, ist halt Q-Chat. Stimmt, die Waffe kann ich mich auch noch erinnern.
Aber da wird richtig gesprüht und gebetet gerade.
Oh, geht doch. Ach doch, Ghost habe ich ein bisschen am Anfang gespielt, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Da habe ich doch auch ein Video hochgelangen, wie meine erste und letzte Runde Ghosts. Da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr, ging mir so offen Sack.
Das war das letzte, was ich richtig gespielt habe.
Boah, da ist man echt schnell gestorben. Boah, da ist man echt schnell gestorben. Und er fasst vor wie auf einem Hardcore Battlefield Server.
Kacke, random Kacke, woran man sterben konnte er. Das sieht total breiig aus, ich glaube das liegt an dem ganzen Blur, da überall auf der Map drauf ist hier.
Ach, das war das erste, das war das erste Cut, wo man Grills im Multiplayer spielen konnte, wo sie sich damals alle aufgeregt haben, warum auch immer.
Die Gegner sind auch wieder die höchsten Kaktobs.
Na gut, es ist jetzt halt nur selektiv, man weiß nicht.
Da weiß ich gar nicht, was ist, Black Ops 3? Nee, Advanced Warfare ist das. Boah, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Hab ich mir, hatte ich mir aber gekauft? Hatte ich mir gekauft? Oder hatte ich mir, ihr doch hat, ne, hatte ich mir? Nee, die Beta haben wir gespielt.
Die Beta habe ich, doch, ich hab's mir gekauft, ich hab's mir gekauft, hab irgendwie drei Singleplayer Missionen gespielt und einmal Multiplayer und hatte keinen Bock mehr.
Irgendwie so, das Advanced Warfare sackt übelst, ja.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal allein das Ironside von dem Ding an.
Also mir hat's nicht gefallen, mein Fall war's nicht.
Ich will noch nicht mal sagen, dass das Rumgespringe per se schlecht ist, ich mein, das hat schon neue Möglichkeiten geboten. Aber mir hat das Setting nicht gefallen und das Game an sich hat mir einfach nicht gefallen.
Warum sehen dem seine Waffen eigentlich so abgedreht aus, überall? Ach nee, weil er gestellt ist, der ist gerade getan, oder? Nee.
Ich glaub, das war das erste Game, wo sie es auch richtig übertrieben haben mit irgendwelchen Sprays und sowas.
Ja, genau, das ist das erste, wo sie richtig angefangen haben mit den übertrieben gestörten, wobei ich glaube, die haben in Black Ops 2 schon angefangen, oder?
Wo war das mit Trang Scale Skin? Das war doch Black Ops 2, ne? Da ging's dann so richtig los mit 30 Milliarden Skins.
Ach stimmt, das war da, ja, das war da, wo man dann verschiedene Waffen getroppt hat, wo es die Waffen noch mal gab mit unterschiedlichen Stats.
Irgendwie kommt aus der Kanne kein Tee raus, was denn hier los geht. Wo es dann die gleichen Waffen mit unterschiedlichen Stats gab.
Also mein Fall war Advanced Warfare nicht. Echt nicht, aber...
Haha, der Dude hat einfach nur da gewartet, bis da einer vorbeispringt.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich glaube, es war noch nicht so übertrieben damals, dass du dir Dual-Wheel Ballistic Knife kaufen konntest, oder halt gegen Echtgeld losen konntest.
Ey, warum hab ich den? Ich hab irgendwas im Hals, warte mal kurz.
Messer an, Messer an, nein. Hatte man da kein Messer, kann das sein? Doch, man hat bestimmt ein Messer, man hat in jedem Konten ein Messer.
Die werden übelst geregt, die Gegner, ja. Jetzt steckt.
Oh nee, geh mal weg. Das hab ich nicht gekauft.
Weil, was ist das schon wieder für ein abgedrehter Waffenskin, ey?
Infinite Warfare, das war das mit dem After Effects Trailer, wo sie im Trailer die Standard After Effects eingebaut haben im Trailer.
Wo sich dann alle drüber lustig gemacht haben, damit die Scheiße im Trailer aussieht.
Infinite Warfare, geh mal fort, ey. Ich mein, das sieht übelst wir aus schon.
Nee, das hab ich nicht gekauft. Ich glaube sogar, das ist das einzige Call of Duty, was ich wirklich nicht gekauft hab.
Den meisten anderen Kram hab ich ja sogar gekauft und danach festgestellt, das gefällt mir nicht mehr.
Der Stellzer sagt, als ich gestern wieder bei KFC gestanden hab, hab ich mich gefragt, was sein Lieblingsfastfood ist. Ich esse in letzter Zeit ausgesprochen wenig Fastfood. Ich war ein paar Jahre nicht mehr bei Burger King, bei McDonalds war ich schon viel länger nicht mehr. KFC war ich auch ewig nicht mehr.
Also mein Lieblingsfastfood, wenn es fastfood ist, ist Subway. Subway Beste, weil das ja nicht wirklich fastfood im eigentlichen Sinne ist, so wie es kein Burger oder kein fritiertes Hähnchen Zeug ist.
Wenn man so in größere Ketten geht und so Subway. Subway. Und danach Pizza Hut. Ich weiß, dass es nicht Pizza Hut heißt, allerdings bin ich total beschuld Pizza Hut zu sagen. Pizza Hut Beste.
Aber Subway, Subway gefällt mir am besten. Sub des Tages. Ich konnte mal eine ganze Weile, Sub des Tages, also Freitags, Freitags ist es immer Tuna. Freitags ist es immer Tuna.
Montags ist es Salami, glaube ich. Dienstags war mal Meatball, aber Meatball gibt es nicht mehr. Ich glaube, Mittwochs, oh fuck, wie war das? Mittwochs war Putenbrust oder so.
Hm. Ich weiß es nicht mal. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Oder war Hemm? Hemm war montags.
Oder? Lass mal überlegen, komm ich? Ah fuck, was war denn? Wir müssen jetzt gleich mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie zusammenkriege.
Nee, ich habe keine Ahnung. Salami? Es war auf jeden Fall, ich glaube montags war auf jeden Fall Salami.
Dann gab es, dann gab es, dann gab es, irgendwann gab es noch Hähnchenbrust. Und nicht Hähnchenbrust.
Turkey war das. Turkey, nicht Hähnchenbrust. Hähnchenbrust gab es glaube ich auch irgendwann am Wochenende, aber da habe ich nie, habe ich nie, war ich nie beim Subway.
Ah fuck, wie war das noch mal? Also Freitags, ich weiß nur Freitags gab es Thunfisch. Freitags gab es Thunfisch. Montags gab es Salami.
Ich glaube Mittwochs gab es Truthan, also Turkey. Und genau, und Donnerstags, ja, Donnerstags bin ich am liebsten hingegangen.
Donnerstags gab es Chicken Fajita, oder wie man das ausspricht. Chicken Fajita, Fajita. Wir gucken jetzt mal, wartet mal, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren hier.
Zapptestages, müssen wir mal nachgucken. Zapptestages. Also, ah, ich habe es verwechselt. Aber gut, kommt aufs gleiche raus im Prinzip.
Im Allianz BMT gab es Montags, das ist ja quasi Salami, bloß unterschiedliche Salami Varianten. Dienstags gab es Salami, genau, das war gar nicht so verkehrt.
Turkey, genau, Mittwochs. Donnerstags, Chicken, beste. Donnerstags bin ich immer hingegangen. War übelst nice. Thunfisch, Freitags. Turkey und Hemms, Samstags. Gut, wusste ich nicht, bin ich Samstag, bin ich kaum zusammen. Chicken Breast war Sonntag. War ich so gut wie nie da. Mein Lieblings, mein Lieblings Subway Sub ist Roasted, ne wie ist das? Roasted.
Diese kleinen Fleischstücke. Was ist das denn? Subways, Subs, was gibts denn? Alle Subs, genau, Zeichner. Okay, den Hemms. Beef and Cheese, genau. Warte mal, ist das das überhaupt? Beef and Cheese, genau. Das war beste. Beef and Cheese. War ganz davon abgesehen, dass die Subs nie so aussehen. Das ist eindeutig ein Photoshop Sub.
Photoshop Sandwich.
Jaja, das war mein Lieblings Sub hier, das da. Beef and Cheese. Beef and Cheese war das beste. Leider gab es das nie als Subs des Tages, allerdings mit Gutscheine. Also ich bin ja im Prinzip eh nur, oder so gut wie immer mit Gutscheine. Also entweder habe ich Subs des Tages gegessen oder es gab Subway Gutscheine.
Die Subway Gutscheine haben sich sogar halbwegs gelohnt, ne. Hatte dann so Dinger wie für 9€ ein Menü oder irgendwie. Der beste Gutschein war, der beste Gutschein ist immer noch gewesen, dass man die zweite Hälfte quasi umsonst dabei gekriegt hat.
Also nicht, ne, besser gesagt, dass man die zweite Hälfte für, ich verstehe nicht mehr wie das war. Zumindest hat man dann für 5€ quasi, konnte man sich für 5€ irgendwie einen 30cm Steak and Cheese holen.
Den einzigen Fehler, den man bei Subway nicht machen darf, ich weiß, also viele Leute mögen ja Subway nicht, weil sie finden das zu kompliziert. Es ist ja auch, sag mal so, es ist auch wenn du das erste Mal reingehst ein bisschen wirr, wie du da bestellen musst, dass du quasi nicht von vorne nach hinten durchläufst, sondern von hinten nach vorne und dass sie dich 3 Milliarden Sachen fragen.
Der Chat 30cm, ja. Den einzigen Fehler, den man bei Subway nicht machen darf, ist, sich von denen irgendwie extra Fleisch, extra Käse, extra sonst was aufschwätzen zu lassen. Weil es bringt überhaupt nichts, das macht das Subway nicht wirklich besser. Es kostet aber richtig viel extra Belag.
Ja und als Käse gibt es, was auch viele nicht wissen, dass es nicht den Standard Käse gibt, du hast Cheddar Käse, Standard Käse und Frischkäse, was du drauf machen kannst.
Na klar kostet es extra. Extra Käse, extra Belag kostet immer extra. Na klar kostet es extra. Es sei denn, die haben die letzten Jahre noch was dran geändert.
Extra Fleisch kostet 250 oder sowas.
Naja, extra, klar. Ansonsten kostet das nicht mehr, aber du hast dich ja schon für was entschieden.
Ja, Felix, da hast du recht. Wenn man sich nicht auskennt, ist Subway bestellen wirklich grausam. Es gibt bei uns jetzt so ein Mexikaner-Subway-Style-Laden.
Ich glaube auch, dass das irgendeine Kette ist und da ist das ähnlich. Ich meine, es ist wie Subway, bloß dass es halt mexikanisches Essen gibt.
Also da bestellt es halt kein Sub, da bestellt es dann irgendwie einen Burrito oder sowas und das ist auch übelst mir, wenn du da zum ersten Mal reingehst.
Die haben dann auch oben halt alles angeschrieben, was es gibt und dann musst du erstmal checken, in welcher Reihenfolge du jetzt für was Dinge auswählen musst.
Nee, nicht Taco Bell, irgendwas anderes.
Guck mal, ich sag's euch gleich.
Da war ich letztens Mittagessen, schmeckt ganz gut. Wenn man ein Menü nimmt, kommt man auch halbwegs günstig. Warum kriegst du ein Burrito?
Die waren echt ganz nice, weil du kannst, wenn du dir Mittagsmenü nimmst, kriegst du so viel trinken, wie du willst, was die meisten Sachen da nicht haben.
Wie hieß das denn? War das das da?
Moment, falsch. Ich hab mich mal verklickt.
Das könnte das eigentlich...
Ja, das ist das. Das ist so Subway-Style-mäßig gemacht. Da blickst du auch... Alter, was ist das für eine Kackseite, Google?
Da blickst du überhaupt nicht durch.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das... Was? Kabel 1? The fuck? Was?
Zumindest ist es so ein Subway-Style-Ding. Und da blickst du auch überhaupt nicht durch, was du bestellen sollst.
Da musst du dir dann erstmal auswählen, du sagst dir prinzipiell, was du für ein Gericht haben willst.
Und dann musst du dir auswählen, ob du Kartoffeln reinhaben willst, ob du Reis reinhaben willst.
Das ist erstmal übelst... Übelstdings hier. Brainbelastend.
Aber ansonsten, es schmeckt ganz okay. Es ist zu teuer. Es ist zu teuer. Die haben keine Preise, denke ich mal, hier stehen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall zu teuer für das, was man...
Können wir mal gucken, ob wir irgendwie Preise... Preise für... Ja, Speisekarte.
Open... Okay, ich weiß nicht, was ich da für eine Seitekarte aufmache.
Und da irgendwie die Preise von... Es ist auf jeden Fall zu teuer. Es schmeckt ganz gut, die Sache ist plus die.
Gucken wir mal. Ja, genau, das ist das. Open Image.
Na ja, wirklich, wirklich gut. Aber ich mein, guck mal.
Einen Taco. Einen Taco für 2,19. Das ist so, du beißt zweimal rein und es ist weg.
Und die Dinger sind auch nicht so voll, wie es auf dem Bild aussieht.
Hier erkennt man gar nichts drauf.
Du bezahlst da irgendwie 10, 12 Euro und bist am Ende nicht hundertprozentig satt.
Also das ist... Das lohnt sich nicht.
Das Einzige, was man machen kann, ist, dass man anstatt...
Dass man als Beilagen noch Tortilla-Chips nimmt, weil da kostet die Packung...
Kostet die wahrscheinlich irgendwie 50 Cent oder so. So ein Sack.
Und da kriegst du immer ordentlich viele. Ist halt auch eigentlich das Schlechteste, was man essen kann dabei.
Aber die sind ein bisschen teuer.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen dem da, wo wir gerade geguckt haben, oder dieser Bully Burrito Laden, würde ich eher...
Bully Burrito mit das Ding futtern.
Auf jeden Fall...
Deutlich mexikanischer auch.
Ist vielleicht nicht für jeden was, also schmeckt sehr nach Mexiko-Würzmischung, ja.
Uuuh.
Hab ich gespielt, fand ich am Anfang nice, hat mir danach überhaupt keinen Bock mehr gemacht.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was man an ihm, finde ich, auch ganz gut erkennt.
Die ersten fünf Call of Duty's, die er gespielt hat, fand er alle übertrieben nice und übertrieben geil.
Und jetzt hat sich das auch so langsam abgenutzt für ihn, ja.
Ab Infinite Warfare fand er eigentlich alles immer nur noch ganz okay, wenn nicht sogar schlecht.
Der geile Sniper, guckt ihn euch an, der geile Sniper, wie er nichts trifft.
Ja, da wird rumgecampt ohne Ende.
Ja, die stehen einfach rum.
Man darf keinen Cod machen, was irgendetwas ist.
Das lädt eh schon zu sehr zum rumsitzen ein an manchen Stellen und manche Perk-Combies und manche Waffen-Perk-Combies.
Und wenn du dann noch die Map so machst, dass es noch viele Great-Hiding-Sports gibt.
Das Problem bei dem normalen Public-Cod-Gameplay ist ja auch ein bisschen, wenn du tryharten willst,
du hast eigentlich gar keine Vorteile dadurch, wenn du super movementintensiv spielst.
Es ist viel besser, du spielst vorsichtig, anstatt halt rum zu rennen.
In Halo zum Beispiel, oder sagen wir mal, das beste Beispiel ist, wenn du dir irgendwie Quake oder Quake Champions anguckst,
egal, irgendein Quake, oder in Halo, da hast du Vorteile dadurch, wenn du dich bewegst.
Das heißt, der, der sich bewegt, wird in der Regel gegen den, der campt, gewinnen.
In Quake ganz einfach, weil er Pickups hat.
Also sprich, wenn du in Quake Pickups hast, also Waffen aufsammelst und Healthbooster aufsammelst,
dann bist du natürlich besser als einer, der campt, ganz klar.
In Halo hast du in der Regel auch Vorteile, wenn du movest.
In CoD ist es halt so, es gibt keine Pickups oder irgendwas, was sie sich auszahlen,
was dich quasi Vorteil verschafft, wenn du dich bewegst.
Das heißt, reines Campen bringt dir auch nichts, da findest du zu wenig Gegner.
Am besten ist in CoD halt nach wie vor defensiv spielen oder halt so weit um sich zu spielen,
dass man möglichst wenig Bullshit abbekommt, und das ist aber auch anstrengend, ja.
Also dass es auf Dauer ist, ist das wirklich anstrengend.
Deswegen fuckt CoD auch so unglaublich ab, wenn man trotz umsichtigem Spielen
und eigentlich aus seiner Sicht nahezu, nenn es mal perfektes Spielen, immer noch Bullshit-Tode stirbt.
Deswegen ist das auch so frustrierend.
Battalion 1944, wie ist deine Meinung dazu? Ich hab so gut wie gar nicht gespielt.
Das, was ich gesehen hab, finde ich, ist das wahrscheinlich ein ziemlich gutes Game.
Ich glaube, es wird allerdings nie großartig public erfolgreich sein,
weil das Kern von Battalion ist halt dieser 6 vs. 6 oder 5 vs. 5 competitive Search-and-Destroy-Modus,
oder halt dieser CS-Style-Bomben-Leak-Modus, und das ist einfach nichts, was die Masse der Leute anspricht.
Das sind so die Stats, die hab ich da in der Regel auch immer in dem Dreh hingekriegt,
weil man war halt überhaupt nicht zufrieden, weil was von alten Games gewohnt war, Noobs zerstören ohne Ende.
Am Anfang hab ich auch richtig viel Playouts 4 gespielt,
und dann hab ich mal ein paar Tage nicht gespielt und hatte nie wieder Bock, das Game anzumachen.
Das lag auch am Skill-based Matchmaking, auf jeden Fall.
Auf welcher Plattform zockst du Cod am liebsten? Ich spiel im Prinzip mittlerweile alles am liebsten auf dem PC.
Allerdings muss man halt sagen, dass Call of Duty und PC so eine Hassliebe ist.
Die mögen sich nicht so richtig.
Die beste Plattform ist darauf zu spielen, finde ich, weil halt Maustastatur beste.
Allerdings sind Spieleranzahlen und Noobs, die man bashen kann, eindeutig auf der Konsole verbreiteter.
Das liegt daran gar nicht, dass die Spieler an sich auf dem PC im Durchschnitt besser oder schlechter werden als auf der Konsole.
Wenn man auf der Konsole schlecht ist, ist man halt richtig schlecht.
Also sprich, wenn man zwei linke Hände am Controller hat, dann ist es nicht so, dass man einfach nur schlecht trifft, man trifft gar nichts.
Mit Maus und Tastatur arbeitet Hida jeden Tag. Man kriegt zumindest die Richtung hin, auch wenn man der größte Kacknoob ist.
Ja, und Cheater auf dem PC kommt auch noch dazu. Ja, richtig.
Das war nicht ein Spiel, den ich jeden Tag spielen konnte.
Vor dem Tag konnten wir das mit Black Ops 1, Modern Warfare 2, Modern Warfare 3 machen.
Ich spielte das für zwei Wochen und dann war ich enttäuscht.
Dann ist mein PS4 auch kaputtgebrochen und das war total devastierend.
Du kannst mich ausdrehen, das ist cool.
Warum spiele ich dieses Spiel nicht?
Du kannst nicht in einem LNG treten.
Man hält ein bisschen viel aus.
Wobei, ich finde, da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich finde es gar nicht so schlimm, dass man in einem Call of Duty mehr aushält.
Es ist die Sache, wie das Game aufgebaut ist.
Also wenn du mehr aushältst und man rennt permanent zwei oder mehr Gegnern über den Weg,
dann ist es schlecht designed im Endeffekt, weil du hast absolut keine Chance.
Selbst wenn du dich gut hinstellst, dass du im Zweifelsfall sogar beide gleichzeitig erwischen kannst,
wenn man so viel aushält, machen die dich einfach platt.
Deswegen bin ich immer noch der Meinung, dass man in Battlefield 3,
oder in Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3,
zeig mal den Memes-Ordner.
Da sind die Bilder, die ich auch overlayen kann.
Und wenn du mehr aushältst, dann klappt das nicht.
In Battlefield 2 und Battlefield 3 kannst du ja wie Papier durch die Gegner durchschießen.
Das heißt, wenn du in Battlefield 3 in den Gang von hinten reingekommen bist,
Leute, nicht hier, wenn du von hinten in den Gang reingekommen bist,
dann hast du einfach mal in Battlefield 3 alles weggesprayt, bis dein Magazin leer war.
Und das ging halt besonders gut, weil du durch die Gegner durchschießen konntest.
Das war in Battlefield 4 schon nicht mehr so.
Das heißt, wenn du in Battlefield 3 in den Gang von hinten reingekommen bist,
dann hast du einfach mal in Battlefield 3 alles weggesprayt, bis dein Magazin leer war.
dann hast du einfach mal in Battlefield 4 alles weggesprayt, bis dein Magazin leer war.
Das heißt, wenn du in Battlefield 3 in den Gang von hinten reingekommen bist,
dann hast du einfach mal in Battlefield 3 alles weggesprayt, bis dein Magazin leer war.
schon tot gewesen oder er hätte sie easy easy weggecockt ja dadurch dass sie so viel
aushalten hat er halt das problem er killt ein ist auf dem anderen und wenn der jetzt
nicht total verknubt ist hätte er ihn jetzt halt gekillt das ist das problem wenn du es machst
dass die gegner mehr aushalten allerdings du permanent mehr als einem gegner gegenüberstehst
funktioniert halt nicht vor allem nicht tdm dann musst du es anders machen dann müsstest du
gucken dass man sich wirklich dass man dass man power-ups durch durch movement über die map
einsammeln kann oder was dann hätte auch eine chance aber so so nicht ja das war klar dass
von hinten dass das einer jetzt wieder geklippt hat ja ja jetzt haben wir uns jetzt haben wir uns
alle kurz angeguckt seit konnte vier ich gehe mal davon aus dass ich etwas dass hier auch ein
paar im chat sind die es wahrscheinlich noch nie noch nie großartig gespielt haben aber mal
eine frage an die leute die die das die die die letzten können auch gespielt haben an die
chance dass hier welche sind ist relativ hoch weil wie gesagt ich habe früher mehr oder weniger
täglich call of duty videos gemacht was gefällt euch am besten welches kot ist würdet ihr sagen
hey das das hat mir am meisten spaß gemacht ich sage nicht kot was man irgendwie remastern rematen
sonst was sollte sondern in der zeit wo ihr das gespielt habt was hat euch am meisten bock
gemacht also ich würde sagen black ops 1 bei mir vielleicht kot 4 aber eigentlich würde ich sagen
black ops 1 mw 2 ok mw 2 es scheint ja super beliebt zu sein da ist die moab ist die moab
das ist die moab wartet mal leute wartet mal kurz da ist die moab genau da ist immer
das war noch zeugs das war noch zeugs meine güden ist die moab
Ah, mann.
How to improve your aiming?
Getting nukes is most overpowered classes.
Irgendwie bin ich geneigt noch ein Video von dem zu gucken. Ich fand das gut.
Yo, was haben wir hier? How to improve your aiming?
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was er erzählt hat.
Ich wollte nicht ganz was anderes gucken.
Oh, Apex.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute. Apex ist so ein Game. Ich hab's nie gespielt.
Aber von allen Battle Royale Games, die es gibt, finde ich Apex am besten.
Obwohl ich es nie gespielt hab.
Schon merkwürdig, oder?
Ich kann es eigentlich überhaupt nicht einschätzen.
Aber Fortnite gefällt mir vom ganzen Konzept her irgendwie nicht.
Ich mag das Rumgebauen nicht.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab's auch nie gespielt.
Also ich rede jetzt rein vom zugucken und so wie ich mir denke, dass die Games sind.
Mir gefällt das Gebauen bei Fortnite nicht.
Ich sag nicht, dass Fortnite kein Skill braucht.
Brauchst ohne Zweifel, vor allem wenn man schnell bauen will.
Mir gefällt das Gebauen nicht.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, auch der Grafikstil von Fortnite gefällt mir nicht.
Aber es ist eindeutig das massenkompatibelste Game.
So, danach hast du PUBG. PUBG hab ich sogar ein bisschen gespielt.
PUBG hat ein Problem, finde ich, wenn man zuguckt.
Und zwar, dass es stinkelangweilig ist zum Zugucken.
Ich weiß, ich hab dir mal ein PUBG-Puppgeturnier gesehen in Südkorea.
Finden sie das ja total geil.
Da haben die ganzen Pro-Squads die PUBG spielen.
Und das ist so langweilig.
Das ist so langweilig, wenn ihr euch mal ein PUBG-Turnier anguckt,
wo ich gar nicht verstehen kann, dass es dazu überhaupt Turniere gibt.
Da gewinnt dann das Squad, was am schönsten, am weitesten weg rumgecampt hat
und die letzten zwei Kills macht.
Das ist so fail PUBG eSport. Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ja, und Apex ist ein Game,
der kannst du von Anfang bis Ende durchrennen und durch Action machen
und übelst ownen, wenn du einfach gut bist.
So sehe ich das zumindest vom Zugucken her.
Außerdem gefällt mir der Grafikstil von Apex am besten.
PUBG hat vom Grafikstil her, möchte ultra realistisch aussehen,
sieht es irgendwie halbwegs, aber läuft nicht richtig.
Fortnite hat halt noch nicht mal einen super stylischen
Comic, Cell-Shading, was auch immer, Look, sondern irgendwie so einen
so einen Mobile-Game-Look.
Fortnite sieht aus wie ein Mobile-Game.
Von der Optik her.
Wie sind diese Mobile-Games, die möglichst neutral aussehen wollen,
dass sie keiner schlecht findet?
Also die ganzen Mobile-Games, die sehen ja alle gleich aus im Endeffekt.
Die sehen alle so hier in der Richtung aus.
Alle so. So sehen die alle aus.
Die ganzen Mobile-Games sehen alle gleich aus.
Die sehen alle gleich aus von der Grafik her und von den Logos her.
Und so sieht halt auch Fortnite aus.
Und deswegen gefällt mir eigentlich Apex so rein vom Zugucken her,
gefällt mir das am besten.
Mir gefällt der Grafikstil am besten.
Das ist nicht realistisch gemacht, sondern es ist weder comicmäßig gemacht,
weder super realistisch, sondern halt so ein bisschen wie Titanfall war,
ist es ja im Endeffekt auch.
Und zum Zugucken ist es einfach am schönsten.
PUBG läuft mittlerweile gut.
Ja, kann sein. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, warum es Apex so verkackt hat.
Weil man muss ja mal sagen, als Apex rausgekommen ist,
so die, so sag mal so zwei, drei Monate oder so lang.
So drei Monate.
Oh, jetzt ist PUBG, da ist irgendein Turnier 100 pro.
PUBG World Cup.
PUBG Nations Cup.
Gucken wir uns mal an, wie wahnsinnig spannend das ist.
Oh, hinter dem Felsenkampen.
Wahnsinn.
High Speed, High Spannung.
Oh, ist das spannend.
Oh, ist das toll, ja.
Auf dem Berg campen, in der Smoke Grenade campen, in der Felsenkamp.
Oh, ist das spannend, ja.
Man sieht es hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist das?
Face Off Camping, Camping Face Off.
Ähm, es schreibt gerade jemand im Chat,
dass er das Seite, die es spielt und gut findet,
ist überhaupt nichts gegen zu sagen.
Selber spielen und einen Turnierstream gucken
sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Selbst ist das mit Sicherheit spannend
und ich kann den Erfolg von PUBG auch verstehen.
Es ist spannend, wenn man selbst spielt.
Ähm, die letzten fünf Minuten passiert was, ja.
Ach so, Apex, ja Apex auch.
Aber Apex passiert konstant was.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, ähm, warum Apex so abgekackt ist.
Die ersten zwei, drei Monate war Apex richtig gut dabei.
Du hattest quasi manchmal Apex vorne,
manchmal Fortnite vorne, meistens Fortnite vorne,
aber die ersten zwei Plätze waren in der Regel
Fortnite und Apex.
Und ich weiß nicht, was die gemacht haben,
dass Apex jetzt so weit hinten geht.
Apex soll laut paar Pros sehr einfach sein.
Okay, aber ja, wir müssen es wissen.
Ich kann jetzt ja nur aus Zuschauersicht sagen.
Apex hat schon leider etwas zu lange gebraucht,
ehe Content kam.
Okay, wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht großartig verfolgt.
Solo-Modus, Du-Modus.
Ich glaube, das liegt einfach daran,
weil Apex an sich darauf ausgelegt ist,
auch durch diese Respawn-Geschichte,
dass du sie im Team spielst.
Aber das neueste Battle Royale,
der neueste Hype, der auch komplett an mir vorbeigeht,
ist diese ganzen Auto-Jazz.
Wie heißt Auto-Battler?
Dieses Spiele-Genre erschließt sich mir auch absolut gar nicht,
wenn ich mir das angucke.
Es erschließt sich mir absolut gar nicht,
warum das so abhebt.
Oder das stimmt nicht.
Es erschließt sich schon, warum das so abhebt.
Ich kann aber nicht verstehen,
wie man da so unglaublich geil drauf sein kann.
Das ist, wie ich sage,
ich verstehe, warum Leute in Black Ops 4
viel Geld für Microtransaction ausgeben.
Aber so wirklich verstehen,
wie man das dann wirklich machen kann.
Also wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das viele machen.
Es ist mir auch irgendwo abstrakt gesehen klar,
warum das viele machen.
Aber wenn ich dann an den Einzelnen denke,
warum macht er das?
Wenn ich dann von mir aus gehe, kann ich nicht verstehen.
Ich hoffe ja.
Verstehst du, das kannst du aber nicht nachvollziehen.
Genau, genau so ist es.
Ich hoffe ja, dass...
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch ein MW2 Video von dem Dude an.
Ich fand das Video von ihm echt nice.
Ich hoffe ja, dass das neue Battlefield
wirklich, also das, was glaube ich immer noch nicht angekündigt ist, oder?
Hast du schon mal was von Ironsight gehört?
Das klingt vom Namen her schon so, als würde es zacken.
Oder?
Oh nein.
Ich glaube nicht.
Das sieht nach China...
Das sieht nach China free to play aus.
Wonka China, ja.
Wonka Java, Java S.
Und ich weiß, was ich sagen wollte.
Ich hoffe ja, dass das neue Battlefield,
wenn es denn dann Bad Company 3 ist,
also das erste, was ich immer hoffe, ist,
dass es würdig ist, sich Bad Company zu nennen.
Und was ich halt wirklich hoffe, ist, dass es gut wird,
weil, also natürlich für mich hoffe ich einmal, dass es gut wird,
weil ich mal wieder ein ordentliches Battlefield zum Spielen haben will,
vor allem auch mal ein Game, wo man mal ein bisschen grinden kann
und auch mal wieder richtig gut drinne werden kann.
Das kriege ich auch mit 35 hin, gegen die ganzen...
Ich meine, die Welt besteht aus Kacknoobs,
das ist überhaupt kein Problem, mit 35 noch Kacknoobs zu ownen.
Also funktioniert immer noch, ja, bin ich sehr zuversichtlich.
Das Game muss halt passen dazu.
Und ich hoffe halt, dass es richtig gut wird,
aber wie gesagt, die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt, ne?
Aber warum ich noch hoffe, dass das neue Battlefield richtig gut wird, ist,
wir hatten jetzt jede Menge Trends die letzten Jahre, ne?
Wie gesagt, hier von dem Battle Royale Zeug zu jetzt Auto Chess.
Zwischenzeitlich gab es mal irgendwelche Card Games wie Hearthstone davor und sonst was.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit für ein 085...
Was ist das für ein 085?
Für ein normales Multiplayer-Shooter-Game ein bisschen Hype zu kriegen.
Aber halt mal ordentlich, ja, mal richtig wieder.
Das kann aber nur funktionieren, wenn das Game eben innere Werte hat, ja?
Also sprich, wenn es nicht einfach nur gut aussieht,
wenn sich das nicht einfach nur die erste Woche mal motivierend spielt,
sondern wenn es eben ein Game ist, wo du auch nach 2 Monaten noch das Gefühl hast,
hey, du logst dich jetzt ein und spielst.
Was Bad Company 2 geschafft hat, was Battlefield 3 geschafft hat,
was teilweise auch Battlefield 4 geschafft hat, aber die Teile danach nicht mehr.
Ich meine, es hat schon seinen Grund, warum die keine Spielerzahlen mehr veröffentlichen.
Gibt's BF1-Stats noch?
Ich mein...
Was ist das?
Wollt ihr uns verarschen?
Das ist doch nix.
Ich mein...
Es spielen mehr Leute Battlefield 4 als Battlefield 1.
Na ja, nicht ganz.
Sagen wir mal, 7, 10, 15, sagen wir mal, 15k-Spiel?
Ah, nicht, na ja, doch.
Sagen wir mal so, es spielen genauso viele Leute Battlefield 4 wie Battlefield 1.
Aber gut, Battlefield 3 spielen kaum noch Leute.
Die haben...
Battlefield 1 spielen bloß keine Ahnung, 2.000 Leute gerade oder so.
Aber 7.000 ist nix.
Leider, leider gibt es keinen...
Gibt es nicht.
Ach, der Typ heißt BF. Gibt es nicht.
Und die wissen warum, die wissen warum es keine Stats mehr releasen.
Ich hab den Typ auf dem Battlefield-1-Event getroffen, der diese Seiten macht.
Da ist ja auch kein Hexenwerk da dran.
Also so eine Seite zu machen, wenn du Zugriff auf eine API hast, wo du die Spielerzahlen und Sachen...
Im Zweifelfall kannst du die Spielerzahlen irgendwie in-game abgabeln.
Das ist ja kein Hexenwerk.
Aber der hat auch gesagt, es ist teilweise richtig schwierig an die Daten dran zu kommen, weil sie immer...
Weil sie immer unliebsamer und weniger gern das Zeug rausrücken.
Man könnte bei Steam gucken.
Na ja, wenn das Spiel auf Steam wäre, könnte man das tun, ja.
Das Spiel ist ja nicht auf Steam.
Battlefield 5 gibt es nur über Origin.
Die wissen schon warum, die wissen schon warum.
Das passiert eigentlich immer auf BF5-Stats, da kommt man auch wegen der Porn-Seite raus.
Ich dachte, das hätten sie vielleicht verkauft.
Oh, Hardline, Hardline gucken wir jetzt noch mal.
Hardline.
Immerhin.
Immerhin, ich meine, 1,5, immerhin, ja.
Okay, 46 Spieler, Battlefield 1, 22, 42, sehr gut.
Ja, und deswegen hoffe ich...
Und deswegen hoffe ich, dass das neue Bad Company was rauskommt, dass das wieder richtig geil wird.
Also, immer unter der Voraussetzung, es ist überhaupt ein Bad Company.
Und sie wissen noch, wie man ein gescheites Bad Company macht.
Da habe ich nämlich persönlich so meine Zweifel, dass sie das noch wissen.
Weil, erstens macht das ein komplett anderer Hersteller.
Das macht ja nicht mal DICE in Schweden.
Da ist jetzt ja hier allerdings...
Die DICE LA ist da irgendwie dabei.
Wenn überhaupt, ja, für Bad Company 3.
Und selbst wenn es DICE in Schweden machen würde, da sind wahrscheinlich alle guten Leute gar nicht mehr dabei.
Hi Max, ich habe Office 365 über die Uni bekommen, leider hat es auch bei mir Skype for Business.
Moment, Skype for Business, das ist der größte Mist überhaupt.
Wie kann ich das am besten deinstallieren?
Ja, dann halt Windows Software deinstalliert, ne.
Wenn du natürlich kein Admin-Rechter auf deinem Rechner hast, dann nicht.
Ansonsten kannst du es doch ganz einfach über die Windows-Software-Verwaltungen deinstallieren, denke ich mal.
Ich habe es noch nie probiert, Skype for Business zu deinstallieren.
Weil Skype for Business ist bei uns halt auf der Arbeit default.
LYNC hieß das früher, mittlerweile heißt das schon Skype for Business.
Skype wird nächstes Jahr eingestellt, nein, Skype for Business wird nächstes Jahr eingestellt, nicht Skype.
Skype for Business wird 2020 eingestellt, das normale Skype nicht.
Wobei ich das normale Skype auch ewig nicht mehr aufhatte, ne.
Na komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch hier MW2 Nuke von dem Typ an, ja, Fortunate. Ich kenne ihn überhaupt nicht, wie lange gibt es ihn denn schon?
Das letzte Video fand ich echt nice, oldest.
Ach, vor drei Jahren, okay, ne, da habe ich ja kaum noch Kot geguckt.
Hier gucken wir mal.
Ich mache, ich mache, ich mache ihn mal wieder ein bisschen leiser.
Ach so, ach so, der Spiel ist lahm.
Was spielt er, was spielt er bei MW2?
ACR? Oh, Auto-Shotgun.
Kennt ihr euch an das Teil, Auto-Shotgun?
Das war, das war eine der meistgehassteste Waffe im ganzen Game.
Die ACR war nice.
Das war eine der meistgehasstesten Waffen im ganzen Game.
Da sind die Leute wie verrückt über quasi um die Ecke gejumpt und haben einfach Trigger durchgehalten.
Aber ACR, ACR war wirklich nice.
Jetzt schrägt er.
Das ist hier links diese U-Boot-Map.
Wie hieß die Map nochmal?
Ich kann mir nicht mehr alle Maps merken.
Wenn ich den Titel sehe, der Map, weiß ich sofort, dass das die richtige ist.
Wie hieß die Map nochmal?
Die U-Boot-Map, MW2.
Subbase, genau, Subbase.
Akimbo war nice, ja.
Der übelste Klitsch-Spot.
Glück, dass er nicht Panic-Neift wurde.
Chopper-Gunner, Chopper-Gunner.
Jetzt erstmal wegrennen, sich an Arsch der Map legen und dann den Chopper-Gunner rausholen.
Glück, dass er nicht weggesnipet wird.
Chopper-Gunner, auf gehts, Chopper-Gunner, gibs ihm.
Auf, Chopper-Gunner.
Nein, hast du nicht.
Das ist halt P2P-Housing in MW2, ne.
ACR war schon nice.
Das war übrigens eine Sache, die ich an MW2 im Nachhinein irgendwie zu schätzen weiß.
Es war fast jede Waffe OP, so kann man auch balancen.
Der Call von Woe, das wäre eher Free gewesen.
Das hat mir eigentlich in MW2 am meisten Spaß gemacht.
Da wurdest du zum größten Teil von dem ganzen Bullshit, den es in TDM gab, verschont.
Ja genau, fast alles hat gewornschottet.
Oder zumindest sehr schnell gekillt.
Keine Predator.
Achso, Harriac stimmt, der braucht einen Nuke.
Den Nuke kannst du keine Predator nehmen.
Du nimmst den Harriac Chopper-Gunner oder den Harriac AC-130 und hoffst, dass deine Killstreaks ordentlich was killen.
Bringt CC-Cleaner in deinen Augen was oder macht der mehr kaputt als es hilft?
Wenn ja, wieso?
Zum Beispiel bei Virenschutz bin ich ja schon auf Windows Defender.
Ich wüsste nicht, wozu man CC-Cleaner brauchen soll.
Registry muss man nicht cleanen.
Das Einzige, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es was bringt, ist, wenn irgendwelche Programme Mist eingetragen haben und man
quasi in Windows irgendwelche Funktionen verstellt haben
und man quasi trotz Deinstallationen vom Programm das Start und Default wieder herstellen will.
Aber das ist ganz selten.
Ansonsten braucht man das nicht.
Auf, AC-130 raus jetzt.
Oh, Predator, Predator, oh, Worn-KS.
Worn-KS, ja.
AC-130 zu callen.
AC-130 im Free-Frawl ist nicht so groß.
Wir werden sehen.
Ich kann das mit meinem AC-130 herstellen.
Das ist schön.
Der Typ ist echt nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube aber, es ist heute auch ein bisschen einfacher.
Ich müsste erstmal mit der MW2 einlegen, weil alle, die jetzt noch COD 4, MW2, COD 5 und so spielen,
das sind wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil die übelsten Lows.
Weil am meisten getryhardet wird eigentlich immer im jeweils aktuellsten Game.
Welchen PDF-Reader brauchst du, um auch reinschreiben zu können?
Ich glaube, das können mittlerweile sogar die PDFs im Browser.
Ansonsten, ich, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht.
Warst du damals Team AC-130, Team Chopper-Gunner?
Beides, beides.
AC-130 hat deutlich mehr Bock gemacht.
Aber mit Chopper-Gunner konntest du fast mehr abgehen, wenn es eine Map wie High-Rise oder so war
und die Gegner dich nicht abgeschossen haben.
Kommt drauf an.
Leute, das ist doch das, was ich vorhin gemeint hab mit enemy AC-130 im Buff.
Der Typ, der so rumschreit, das Voice Acting war übelst nice.
Jawoll.
Da ist die Moab.
Komm, drei Kills noch.
Zwei Kills, zwei Kills.
Jawoll.
Der geile Schneiber, der Schneiber-Dude, das waren die besten, die geilen Schneibern wollten oder nichts getroffen haben.
Jetzt muss der Nuke zünden und messen.
Ich hoffe, er messert diesmal.
Messen.
Sonst zählt die Nuke nicht, ne?
Springen.
Ja, drehen und messen.
Ah.
Nuke zählt nicht.
Direkt Nuke aberkannt.
Oh, UMP-Silencer.
Das war auch richtig OP.
Diesen Effekt fand ich damals übelst nice.
Da hab ich sogar Singleplayer-Games aufgemacht.
Also, ne, ne.
Halt, ne, alleine auf die Map, um mir diesen Effekt genauer anzugucken.
Den fand ich damals übelst nice.
Spass.
Oh Gott.
Ist der UMP-45 mit Silencer?
Hör auf, Harry.
Die Perken sind wirklich nicht so wichtig für diese Waffe.
Die UMP war übelst nice.
Oder so.
Mag die Map nicht.
Wasteland war auch dumm.
ML2 hatte an sich eh viele dumme Maps.
Schon krass, wie wir alle noch so viel von einem 10 Jahre alten Spiel wissen.
Ähm.
Na ja, alles, was du mal 100 Stunden gegrindet hast, wirst du dir merken.
Ich kann dir beispielsweise heute noch fast jede RA und jeden Skill in Dark sagen.
Ich kann dir fast noch jedes einzelne Level in Folge von Half-Life 1 sagen.
Also, vieles, was du viel gegrindet hast, merkste dir einfach.
Wegsprayt.
Äh.
War nicht Highrise.
Äh, Row, Row.
Irgendwas mit Row ist die Map doch, oder?
Deck Row? Ne, äh.
Ist das nicht irgendwas mit Row, diese Map?
Sky Row, Sky, Skid Row.
Skid Row, Skid Row.
Ja.
Deckt.
Mit dem Loch in der Decke, genau.
Schön durchsprayen hier.
Ich hab Harriers, da ist eine Claymore auf dem Boden, das ist echt komfusierend.
Denen hier rein.
Gut, alles klar.
Am nächsten Duke, Gorgor.
Nein, ich kann nicht jetzt.
Ich hoffte, dieser Typ hatte keine Noob-Tubes, danke Gott.
Alles klar, Harriers.
Die Spass, also das in MW2 war das eines meiner Lieblings-Secondaries, Spass 12, weil das hat sich halt übelst nice angefühlt, wenn du quasi um die Ecke gejumpt bist und irgendwann one-shotted hast. Das einzige Problem an der Spass 12 ist Painkiller gewesen.
Du konntest so abgehen mit der Waffe, wenn die Gegner keinen Painkiller hatten, aber sobald die Gegner Painkiller hatten, warst du in der Regel tot, weil du drei Schuss eigentlich gebraucht hast.
Ja, aber die Spass 12 war übelst nice.
Jawoll, Chopper Gunner.
Warum trifft der den nicht?
Chopper Gunner ASMR-Video.
Ja, das ist so ein guter Punkt, um einen Chopper-Gunner auf Skid Row zu bekommen. Wenn du diesen auf der Außenseite spawst, ist das ein einfaches Nuke, jedes Mal.
Und wenn er meinen Chopper-Gunner nicht ausgelöst hat, hätte er wahrscheinlich so viele Töne bekommen. Wir werden uns das trotzdem anrufen, denn ich bin gerade da gespritzt. Ich habe noch eine Klasse übrig. Take a guess und schiebe es in die Kommentare.
Ich hatte nicht erwartet, dass er auf Skid Row gespielt hat, aber wenn er den Chopper-Gunner ausgelöst hat, war es wirklich zu Ende.
Ich habe die RPG gewählt, weil sie extrem übergebracht sind.
Ja, stimmt.
War das das M240 oder was war das?
War das das PKG? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das für eine LMG war.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die Klasse habe ich gar nicht so als Super-OP in Erinnerung. Also richtig OP war Akimbo-Model. Akimbo-Model mit diesem Range-Erhöher dran.
Der PD war das.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe, Leute, so kannst du es auch balancen, das Game, in dem einfach jede Waffe OP ist.
Das war übrigens auch eine Kack-Map. MW2 hatte viele Kack-Maps, finde ich.
Wasteland, hör mal auf. Müll. Huge Müll, die Map.
Ich meine, Wasteland war ein Free-For-All oder generell Wasteland war cool, wenn du als erstes deine Killstreaks hattest.
Wenn du nicht als erstes deine Killstreaks hattest, konntest du eigentlich Ragequitten und nächste Runde suchen.
Ja, die Killstreaks sind auf Wasteland übelst krass.
Boah, das fuckt ab. Das fuckt ab, wenn du kurz vor der Nuke bist und dann aufs Dach kriegst.
High-Rise ist gut, Terminal ist auch gut, ja.
Schon wieder fast zwei Stunden on bin.
Ich fand die Sounds auch irgendwie cool, der Waffen.
Das hört sich wenigstens, im Vergleich zu irgendwie dem futuristischen Kotz, hört sich das wenigstens noch nach normalen Schüssen an.
Stimmt, warum sind eigentlich nur vier Leute drin?
Okay, du siehst schon mal nachher, dass es wieder Bot-Gegner sind, dass keiner den Harrier abschießt.
Topper, jawoll.
Zeig's uns, ja.
Debated.
Das war kein solch guter Topper-Gunner.
Aber die Gegner sind auch irgendwie failen, ne?
Aber was willst du machen?
Leute, das ist das, was ich immer sage, du brauchst kacke Gegner, um so was wie einen 25er-Killstreak hinzukriegen.
Wie willst du das gegen gute Gegner machen?
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Meinung zum nächsten Kotz, Bock drauf?
Äh, eindeutig, jaja.
Also nachdem wir uns das letzte Sonntag angucken haben, ich hab so bauchgefühlmäßig übels Bock auf das neue Kotz.
Ich überleg mir aber ernsthaft, nach dieser ganzen Microtransaction-Lootbox-Skamaas-Geschichte von Black Ops 4, mir den Kram doch nicht zu kaufen.
Weil ich hab's vorhin schon gesagt.
Ähm, was bringt's dir, wenn du ein richtig gutes, wenn du ein Game hast, wo du dann auch richtig gut drinne bist, wo du das übelst crynest,
und nach ein, zwei Monaten wird's zerstört durch so eine Scheiße.
Da hast du eigentlich gar keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ich will das, ich will das, also ich würde das schon gerne spielen, aber ich will's nicht, ähm, ich will's eigentlich nicht supporten.
Aber okay.
Yuke! Da ist die Moab!
Oh lasst den! Das hab ich mir ganz vergessen. Painkiller und lasst den!
So kacke Perks, äh.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn wir 4.000 Likes geben, glaube ich, habe ich es vorhin gesagt.
Und
den kannst du mit Sicherheit reduzieren und es trotzdem suchterregend genug machen und
random genug machen und Geld aus der Tasche zierisch genug machen, ohne dass so ein hoher
gesetzlich problematischer
Glücksfaktor drinne ist.
Und woran sie sich ja hauptsächlich auch stören, ist noch nicht mal der Glücksfaktor bei Lootboxen, sondern, dass du nicht genau weißt, wie deine Chancen sind.
Mal ganz ehrlich, ja, als würde es irgendjemand davon abhalten, Glücksspiel zu betreiben, weil er weiß, dass seine Chancen gering sind.
Es spielen so viele Leute Lotto, obwohl sie wissen, die haben faktisch keine Chance zu gewinnen.
Es spielen so viele Leute, was sich in irgendeinem Casino was, obwohl sie eigentlich keine Chance haben zu gewinnen.
Die sagen dann, ja ok, aber ich bin jetzt der, jetzt ist es soweit, eins von 40 Millionen Chancen, jetzt, heute, heute ist es soweit, ja.
Also, es wissen viele Leute, wie gering ihre Chancen sind, und trotzdem machen sie es, deswegen glaube ich kaum, dass wenn sie verpflichtet sind, die Chancen auf Lootbox zu schreiben, dass das irgendwie was, was ändert.
Es ist ein bisschen wie der Disclaimer, der man am Strand aufstellt, Achtung Haie.
Schwimmen auf eigene Gefahr, Achtung Haie.
Es hindert, es wird keinen dran hindern, da schwimmen zu gehen, und es wird wahrscheinlich auch keiner von Haien gefressen.
Aber für den Fall der Fälle steht es halt da, und für den Fall der Fälle, in short, steht es halt da, dass sie nicht verklagt werden.
Ich mag den Typ irgendwie, also, ich hab von ihm nur nie was geguckt, ich finde die Videos sind cool.
Also, wenn euch die zwei Sachen gefallen haben, überguckt, könnt ihr mal bei ihm vorbeigehen? Subscriben.
How to improve your aim, oh, da ist Overwatch dabei, das wollen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Hello everyone, my name is Overwatch, dazu hab ich ja auch mal ein Video gemacht, ich hab mal ein Video gemacht, ähm, das war nicht zu aim an sich,
das war irgendwie drei, drei, drei Tipps, die einem in jedem, die einem in jedem Game helfen besser zu werden, so in der Richtung.
Ich hab ja auch mal die ein oder anderen Tipps und Tricks Videos gemacht, mal gucken, was er uns erzählt, wie man besser aimen kann.
Moment, wie groß ist der Typ? 20k, nicht viel. War das mit der Minimap? Nee.
Das war was ganz Allgemeines.
Wie sind wir besser in jedem Game?
Advanced Warfare Erwartung, boah.
Advanced Warfare Erwartung, boah. Es hat einer für mich was, es hat einer was zu meinen Overwatch Videos geschrieben, okay, ähm, nee, nee, das war es, das war es eigentlich, hauptsächlich ging es in dem Video damals darum, wenn ich mich recht entsinnen kann, was ich damals erzählt habe in dem Video,
dass es hauptsächlich darum ging, dass man sich selbst eingesteht, wenn man was verkehrt gemacht hat. Das bringt generell, das ist durch die Bank weg, egal in welchem Game oder nicht nur in Games, man wird nur besser, wenn man selbst einen Blick drauf hat, was man verkackt.
Natürlich ist es auch sinnvoll, sich andere anzugucken, die gut spielen oder einen, der sich sein eigenes Gameplay anguckt. Aber das beste, was man am Anfang eigentlich machen kann ist, viel grinden, viel grinden und sich permanent notieren, bzw. aufschreiben, notieren, wenn man gerade merken kann, dass man etwas verloren hat.
anguckt aber das beste was man am anfang eigentlich machen kann ist viel
grinden, viel grinden und sich permanent notieren bzw. aufschreiben, notieren wenn
man gerade merkt man hat schlecht reagiert, man hat was schlechtes
gemacht und auch im nachhinein replays angucken, eigentlich eigenes gameplay
analysieren und und sich einzugestehen dass man das man verkackt hat ist
eigentlich das beste was man machen kann
today i want to cover something very general but also very important
dann zeige uns mal wie man aimt
so i'm gonna start by totally contradicting the point of this video
people really overestimate the importance of aim don't get me wrong
it is important hat er recht hat er recht ohne scheiß das habe ich auch schon in
ganz vielen videos gesagt aiming allein ist nicht alles es ist es ist guckt euch
shroud an, guckt euch shroud an ja wenn du gut aimen kannst kannst du einfach gut
aim kannst du jedem spiel gut aimen aber was was was richtig unterschätzt wird
ist generelles movement durch die bank weg usefules was scheiß satz durch die
bank weg unterschätzt wird standard shooter movement wie praktisch das in
jedem game ist also wenn man wenn man sich einfach mal
dran gewöhnt hat wie man sich in wie man sich in games ordentlich bewegt bringt
überall was egal ob man es auf der konsole spielt auf dem pc spielt und mit
mit mit dem ordentlichen bewegen auf einer map ich meine damit jetzt nicht
dass man nach links und rechts laufen kann mit ordentlich bewegen ist ja auch
gemeint um nicht ordentlich in dem shooter oder in dem game bewegen zu
können musst du immer im kopf behalten wie sich die gegner bewegen und das
führt dann dazu dass du dir quasi schon im vorfeld überlegst wo wo kommt der
gegner jetzt her wo kommt der gegner jetzt her und wenn
du das gut kannst und das ist ziemlich ziemlich spiele sind auf jeden fall
ziemlich shooter übergreifen wenn du das gut kannst ist ein aim gar nicht mehr
so extrem wichtig weil du eh schon mal prinzipiell in die gleiche richtung
guckst oder weil du prinzipiell schon mal in die richtige richtung guckst
richtig gute spieler guckt euch guckt euch zs cs go pros an da ist es ganz
selten so dass die jetzt amen müssen so hier den da einmal einmal irgendwie 180
grad oder oder oder von links und nach rechts um vor allem zs ist ein muster
beispiel dafür dass du schon dadurch dass du dich eben gut auskennst im
spiel dass dein dein crosshair ungefähr da ist wo der gegner ist ich sag nicht
dass zs groß nicht amen können die können übelst krass mehr aber zs ist ein
muster beispiel dafür was es ausmacht sich ordentlich zu bewegen in dem game
und dass zs ist es relativ langsam in apex ist es relativ schnelles movement
in quake ist es schnelles movement in kot ist es auch relativ schnelles movement
das macht einfach viel aus dass man einschätzen kann wo die gegner her
kommen und das ist in jedem shooter ziemlich ähnlich genauso was auch was
auch einfach erfahrung irgendwie ausmacht ist dass man sofort erkennt
welche stellen auf der map gut sind und welche schlecht zum beispiel wenn ich
war wenn ich wenn ich weiß die gegner sind wahrscheinlich hinten weiß ich
dass die stelle hier oder hier oder hier wahrscheinlich ganz gut ist dass ich
wahrscheinlich würde ich wahrscheinlich läuft so halt so ja wahrscheinlich
läuft so oder aber läuft so am besten halt dass du deckung an der wand hast so
ich habe apex noch nie gespielt ja aber das wäre sieht für mich ganz nach
sinnigen movement aus so in den da den da außen rum hier hinter reingucken
ja und dass du einfach weiß dass du einfach
einschätzen kann zwar sinnvoll auf der map ist dass das zum beispiel knackt ist
auf der map in der mitte in dem tunnel zu stehen wenn du am rand der map in dem
lagerhaus aus dem fenster gucken kannst das sind einfach so sachen die die
lernt man mit der zeit und die bringt einen in jedem in jedem game was genauso
wie treppen treppen ist in jedem game gut wenn man oben steht an der treppe das
sollte auch jedem klar sein und nicht einfach nur von oben
hinten sondern einfach auch von oben quasi an der seite runter gucken der
typ der die treppe hochgesprintet kommt kriegt aufs maul in 99 prozent der fälle
ja das stimmt 104 chats monitor muss sein also das ist tatsächlich was wo
ansonsten sage ich ja hardware upgrade keiner solange solange das game
ordentlich läuft es macht jetzt nicht so also mit ordentlich läuft meine ich
jetzt nicht 45 fps sagen wir sie keine ahnung irgendwie mindestens 60 besser
100 plus fps am besten natürlich 200 plus was auf jeden fall sein muss in
144 144 herz monitor das macht auch jemand der sagt in
dem game besser das ist ein riesen unterschied es fühlt
sich einfach viel flüssiger du kannst auch du kannst auch genauer zielen
kannst du kannst alles genauer machen 144 herz ist das beste was es gibt
und ein ordentlich internetanschluss natürlich ich erinnere nur mal an die
fünf an den fünf millisekunden ping auf die battlefield server in köln das war
nice damals haben sie alle gedacht irgendwie ich wohne im keller vom
rechenzentrum oder so oder oder ich ich arbeite bei dem haus den anbieter oder
so fünf fünf millisekunden ping nach köln
braucht man einen krassen pc für 144 herz monitor nur muss einfach die
details runterstellen das ist auch das ist übrigens auch was
was ich glaube ich damals in dem video gesagt habe dass es bei den meisten
competitive shootern war den meisten competitive games aber sagen bleiben
wir bei shootern die man eben ernsthaft spielt meistens sinnvoll ist ausnahmen
steht in die regel aber meistens sinnvoll ist die details so weit wie
nötig runterzustellen und mit nötig meine ich nicht dass es flüssig läuft
das ist eins ich meine hauptsächlich damit dass das game eben gewisse sachen
ausschaltet die nervig sind zum beispiel wenn das game nervige spiegelungen hat
oder irgendwelche rays von der sonne die ein planten oder sowas einfach
rausschalten wenn man es ausschalten kann wenn es irgendwie in overwatch am
anfang irgendwelche büsche gab die genervt haben einfach detail zu
unterstehen hat man dann hat man keine büsche mehr keine büsche sieht zwar
scheiße aus aber keine büsche sind rein aus rein aus
gameplay technisch im sicht dass man besser spielt natürlich besser weil man
die gegner die in den büscheln sind
einfach runterstellen brauchst keinen super pc oder viel für chats monitor
dran details auf low anti-elase übrigens dass das spät das
wichtigste was ich abschalten müsste sind irgendwelche post processing post
processing blur und sonst was also wo quasi das game gerendert ist und
danach noch mal ein frame durch irgendwie durch irgendwelche post
processing sachen dran ist also alles was irgendwie input lag verursacht muss
weg jegliches post processing muss aus was auf jeden fall aus muss was das
allerwichtigste ist was aus muss ist motion blur also wenn man sich bewegt
dass die umgebung verschwimmt das muss weg dann hat man nämlich von 144
scherz fast nix wenn man den wenn man den mist anlässt wenn wenn es geht würde
ich auch jegliche art von hat also von von bobbing sowohl kopfgewackel würde
ich ausschalten ich würde einfach mal alles auf low stellen mit dem game
angucken was ich anschalten würde ist ganz normal das multisempling anti
lasing oder oder die bisschen billigere varianten davon zumindest zweifach das
anti lasing würde ich einschalten weil es ist oftmals echt ätzend wenn es wenn
es wenn es gar so sehr kannten hat
er hat die skills die get over looked bei skal 23 sekunden war mal im video
schon drin und ich habe schon irgendwie zehn minuten gelabert wie es irgendwie
aus wie es irgendwie muss weg wie es irgendwie muss ganz schnell weg
da muss ich ja auch mal überlegen umso schneller das game rendert
umso besser egal ob der monitor das anzeigen kann
umso schneller das game rendert um so wenig input lag immer
schaltest du motion play aus aus immer immer aus
das erste was ich mache ich lass meistens
selbst bei singleplayer games
ich schalte motion play immer aus ich mach singleplayer games
aber meistens in den
in den in den settings wie sie kommen beziehungsweise schalte erst mal alles
auf hoch meine rechner ist ja ganz gut aber motion play immer aus immer
some people because they're so focused on aiming if e-sports were ever taught in
schools you'd probably learn about the first person shooter fundamentals or
something like that there are a set of skills that transfer between games and
they are well fundamental to being a good player
those things are aim movement positioning and game sense
ich glaube wir müssen uns das video gar nicht angucken weil das im prinzip
exakt das ist was ich eben gerade erzählt habe
das genauso ist es genauso ist es
aim ist wirklich nur ein teil davon
so yes aim is definitely right up there as one of the most important skills
but it's pretty common for people to focus so hard on clicking heads
that they stand out in the open they move predictably and play to aggressively
or passively when
wir haben ein ungesubscriber im chat
du wirst dich wie zu hause fühlen ich mache nämlich gerade reaction videos
ich habe keine ahnung ob er das erwacht
in that situation your aim could be well above average but you'll still lose
spectacularly because you were standing in a bad spot and making yourself an easy
target have you ever watched pro players and seen the difference in their
accuracy between pub stomping on twitch and playing against other pros in real
matches
their aim stays the same they don't just get worse because they're playing
against other good players but their accuracy drops
richtig richtig
das kommt drauf an wie sich der gegner bewegt
du hast du hast die kack noobs die es gerade mal schaffen von a nach b zu laufen
und ihr hast die guten spieler die auf das reagieren was du machst beziehungsweise
standardmäßig und nicht so kacke wege laufen
why? because pro players have great movement as well a good player can dodge shots
just as well as they can make them so
do not neglect the other fundamentals but with that being said
you need to have at least some level of aiming competence
you could have great hard to predict movement and dodge a load of shots
you could be standing in a great spot and you could perfectly predict when and
where someone might come around a corner
but if you can't move your crosshair to that opponent's head it's all for
nothing
so let's learn how to aim i'm gonna split this
übrigens leute hab ich euch schon erzählt wenn ihr einen twitch
wenn ihr einen amazon prime account habt
wenn ihr das ganze kostenlos mit eurem twitch account verknüpfen
und ihr könnt damit einmal im monat einen streamer eurer wahl mit einem tier
one sub kostenlos unterstützen oder dass euch was kostet
und das streamer bekommt das gleiche von twitch ohne dass ihr was bezahlen müsst
nur mal so angemerkt ne
ich wollte ich wollte es ja nur mal gesagt haben dass das mit
es gibt immer noch leute die wissen das nicht an das mit
amazon prime machen kann
es sind sie auf jenna holen und tritt spiel ist kostenlos
dank für die holen bitts
halbkorb
doch guck mal weiter
wir sind übrigens eins ab vom sub goal entfernt
da wieder
sind wir tatsächlich
denn für tatsächlich
wir kriegen wir kriegen noch ein neues emote
ich ging noch ein neues emote ohne emotes zu haben
anlacki doch tritt spiel im pock das auch sehr laut funktioniert
dankeschön
der rio
fahrt lach
dankeschön pock
samus
jetzt geht es aber ab hier tritt spiel ohne ende hier
der tschack 96 das subtrain
samus
dankeschön
ein original tier 1
pock dankeschön
ich sag euch leute sellout
man muss einfach regelmäßig sellout machen
dankeschön
jetzt ab
dada haltet das subtrain ist am start
cute
weiß
ich glaube jetzt haben wir sogar wirklich noch einen weiteren emote slot
mit dem unterschied dass ich halt keine emotes gemacht hab bisher
ich glaub ich hab jetzt zwölf
ich glaub ich hab jetzt zwölf emote slots
ähm
11, 11 oder 12 emote slots und ich hab nicht einen emote hochgeladen
wir haben übrigens ein neues, wir haben ein neues, ne neues frankerfaces z emote
ne habt ihr schon gesehen
lolw haben wir noch, haben wir jetzt lolw
ein bisschen was anderes
weil wir haben null, wir haben null 3d
wir haben sonst was aber aber null lolw haben
lolw hatten wir noch nicht
lolw haben wir noch nicht
golden kappa check ja genau golden kappa check
null 3d geht anders
so geht das
null 3d alles großgeschrieben
ok jetzt gucken wir einfach die krassen aimtips an, danke für die ganzen subs
subscriber
a few different parts so
first let's quickly start with gear and sensitivity
i'd actually like to skim over this somewhat because it's another area that
people focus too much on
having said that if someone says having a good mouse doesn't matter
they're talking crap
das stimmt, natürlich
mouse macht nen unterschied vor allem
nicht einfach irgendeine mouse
sondern ne mouse die zu einem passt
das ist nämlich grad das wichtige
es bringt überhaupt nichts zu sagen ey
progamer xy hat die und die mouse
das ist vielleicht ein hinweis dazu was man sich mal anschauen könnte
an mouse allerdings
das wichtigste ist dass man ne mouse findet die zu einem passt
ich hatte die letzten jahre
hatte ich drei stück
und ich glaube ich hab jetzt die mouse gefunden die zumindest vom aktuellen
line up
am besten
der versandtrack so was stimmt, den wollte ich euch ja auch noch mal zeigen wie der neueste
versandtrack so aussieht
aber erstmal zum thema mouse, ich hatte ne ganze zeit lang jetzt die g502 von logitech
die hab ich jetzt auf der arbeit
da werd ich immer komisch angeguckt teilweise weil ich hier die
übelste
leuchtende gaming mouse am start habe
für die arme ist die mouse cool
mit dem endless laufrad und sowas, wirklich nice, kann man nix sagen
das problem ist an der g502
warum ich sie nicht mehr verwendet hab ist die war zu schwer
die war zu schwer für meinen geschmack
war die zu schwer
dazu kommt
dass sie sogar noch gewichte hat die man rein machen kann dass sie noch schwerer wird
und mir war die schon ohne gewichte zu schwer
an sich ne richtig gute mouse
also wenn man mal von dem gewicht absieht
von dem wie sie in der hand liegt auch der gummi griff hier neben
von den features her, vom driver her
von den funktionen her
auch dieser sniper button hier unten
ist das ne super mouse, wirklich ne ganz tolle mouse
mir ist sie bloß n ticken zu schwer
danach hab ich mir gedacht ey komm
wir sind jetzt hier quasi von der monster mouse was features angeht
gehen wir mal zu ner leichtgewichtigen mouse die quasi keine features hat
da hab ich mir ne ec2a gekauft
also ich denke man sieht
man sieht den unterschied hier auch schon ganz gut
ähm zwischen den mäusen
das ist das
viel klassischer kann ne mouse nicht aussehen ne
du hast hier oben zwei tastenden mausrad und links und rechts zwei
zwei knöpfe, fertig
dpi stellst unten an nem schalter um, das ding hat unten auf der unterseite nen dpi schalter
ähm
allerdings
ist die qualität von der mouse nicht sonderlich gut
ich musste die zurück schicken, weil bei der ersten haben die
an die tasten geknazt und sind hängen geblieben nach ein paar wochen
was ja nicht sein darf, mein maustasten die knasen und vor allem hängen bleiben
da ich hab overwatch viel ana gespielt und ana musst du ja quasi permanent
oder zumindest relativ oft amen
und ähm
einzelne shots treffen
und das war hauptsächliche mausbelastung war halt bei der mouse damals
der hier halt
zielen und
und ich bin halt jemand der bei single shots ziemlich auf die maus haut
oder ich hau nicht auf die maus, ich drück die maustasten fest
wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich ähm
präzise single shots machen, das ist so eine angewohnheitssache
und ähm
an sich war die maus gut, die war schön leicht und alles
problem war erstens die qualität fand ich nicht so gut
und zweitens
dass es überhaupt keine überhaupt keine maustreiber gibt
ähm fand ich dann auch kacke
mein mainboard
mein mainboard hat angeblich die möglichkeit
dass man jede usb, wenn man, das mainboard hat so einen so einen so
gaming mouseport, da hat er blödsinn, aber
angeblich hat es die möglichkeit dass man quasi
jegliche maus die man daran anschließt mit so einer äh
srock
ähm
software kann man dann quasi macros machen und so
totaler fail funktioniert nicht
die software gibt es noch nicht mal richtig für dieses mp, komplett für den arsch
also ok ähm
du bist nicht ganz zufrieden mit der maus
das heißt nicht, dass ihr nicht zufrieden sein könnt, die maus an sich ist topmaus
also auf jeden fall
für schnelle games finde ich deutlich angenehmer als eine g502
ähm
und jetzt hab ich eine
logitech, moment was
eine g403 habe ich jetzt
mit kabel, eine g403
das finde ich ist für mich persönlich die perfekte mischung aus beiden mäusen
du hast so eine basic, so eine basic maus an sich
links und rechts zwei tasten, relativ ähnliche
relativ ähnlich, ähm vom vom vom shape her
ihr merkt es leute, ich hab, ich hab immer, ich hab mittlerweile echt
probleme um alle deutsche setze auszusprechen
äh von der form her
ist das, ist das recht ähnlich, so sorry die sind ein bisschen breiter vorne
aber die knöpfe fühlen sich besser an, du hast hier oben noch so ein extra knopf den du
belegen kannst und
du hast halt einen ziemlich guten maus driver dabei
wo du macros einstellen kannst
und ähm
dinger machen ja
und die drei mäuse hab ich letzten
wir waren in den letzten zwei drei jahre durch
und bin jetzt bei der hängen geblieben, das heißt nicht dass ich bei der in zukunft auch hängen
bleiben werde
aber mit der bin ich jetzt wirklich zufrieden
das um genau und wieder zum zum
die g403 hat doch ein kaputtes mausrad
also meine ich
also die hat kein problem mit dem mausrad
und ähm deswegen ist es wichtig
worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte ist
das im prinzip was er auch hier sagt
macros ist wichtig
aber es ist nicht wichtig eine einfach eine gaming maus zu haben oder oder die
maus zu haben mit der ein anderer gut spielen kann
es ist wichtig eine maus zu haben die zu einem selbst passt
zu dem wie man spielt
bei der g502 ist das problem weil ich hier grad overwatch sehe
hast hier zarya am start
und
am anfang von overwatch hat man zarya
ein bisschen anders gespielt
da war es im trend dass man ich glaube das liegt auch daran weil sie danach ein
bisschen was geändert haben an den schilden und sowas
ähm
damals hast du zarya immer abwechselnd gemacht oder versucht abwechselnd zu
machen rechtsklick und linksklick
und ähm um das richtig zu machen musst du permanent quasi so machen
und ich hab gemerkt dass ich das mit der g502
das war so die zeit wo ich gedacht habe hier jetzt
die hat krasser overwatch pro ja
ähm
musstest du halt
permanent hin und her machen
und das habe ich nicht gemacht mit der 502
und dann habe ich mir eine andere maus gekauft mit der habe ich das dann gemacht weil die mir zu schwer war
ihr wisst ihr wisst doch was ich meine ich wollte mal ab und zu den ein oder anderen esl cup spielen und nicht total abkacken
wir waren eigentlich auch ganz gut für die zeit
es gab auf jeden fall mehr leute die deutlich schlechter waren als wir
ey wir haben sogar ein wir haben sogar damals das war unsere beste woche wir haben wir haben damals haben wir ein pro team also pro team in anführungsstrichen
ein team was damals ähm zum zum take take tv home ist das home seat
seat story cup oder so eingeladen war besicht im im im im im im im in weekly cup ja
es war unsere beste woche
die
das Kapitän-Season ein bisschen anders.
Also ich bin der Meinung,
ich bin der Meinung, eine gute Default Sensitivity,
womit man die meisten Games ganz gut spielen kann.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel
und in Overwatch ist es halt auch ganz abhängig davon,
ob ich Widow oder Lucio oder sowas spiele
oder in anderen Games.
Ich finde eine gute Default Sensitivity,
wenn du, also 800 DPI habe ich auch, habe ich auch eingestellt,
aber die Sensitivity in-Game finde ich defaultmäßig ganz gut,
wenn man guckt, dass man mit einmal über das Mousepad fahren,
wenn man, es sei denn mal so einen halben Tisch als Mousepad,
wenn man so ein normales Mousepad hat,
normales, ein bisschen größer als normales Mousepad vielleicht,
wenn man einmal drüber fährt oder fast drüber fährt
und sich 360 Grad dreht.
Das ist für CS, für CS-Pros ist das natürlich übertrieben schnell.
CS-Pros fahren über ihr 5 Meter Mousepad und drehen sich zur Hälfte.
Das ist übertrieben zu sagen,
aber ich finde so eine Standard Sensitivity,
mit der man zumindest mal in jedem Game nicht total abkackt,
ist Mousepad 360.
Das ist erstmal ganz okay, von da kann man dann weiter einstellen.
DPI, double those values, and if you use 1600, then halve it.
There are outliers who have slightly higher or lower sensitivities,
but the vast, vast, vast...
800 DPI kriege ich doch im Desktop-Modus noch?
Nö.
Überhaupt nicht, du kannst ja...
Okay, ich habe jetzt hier...
Wo sieht man die Standard, ich glaube 8 oder so?
Oh fuck, wo stellt man das überhaupt ein?
Ich finde die Settings gar nicht mehr, ich glaube 6 von 10.
4 von 10, 6 von 10 stellt man glaube ich in Windows immer ein.
Das ist so Standard.
Und ich bewege den jetzt...
Einmal über den Bildschirm, da bin ich...
Da bin ich keine Ahnung...
Da habe ich...
Wenn ich den jetzt hier einmal rumbewege, von da nach da,
habe ich im Windows-Modus irgendwie knapp ein halbes Mousepad.
Also...
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich kriege ohne mein Hand...
Also ich kann von unten links nach oben rechts...
Kann ich das ohne...
Also natürlich muss ich die Hand ein bisschen ausstrecken.
Kann ich das machen ohne, dass ich mein Handgelenk großartig übers Mousepad bewege.
Adrenalin-Shakes.
Den Ausdruck habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Aber erlebt hat es wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal,
wenn er quasi bei 24 Kills vor der Nuke ist
und dann übelst verkrampft und den Gegner nicht trifft,
weil er so aufgeregt ist.
Das ist ein wirklich schweres Problem zu haben.
Aber wenn du ein CSGO-Spieler bist,
die sich auf jeden Fall an andere FPS wechselt,
möchtest du dich ein bisschen auf die Sensitivität aufreißen.
Aber für fast jeder andere ist es unwahrscheinlich,
dass deine Sensitivität zu niedrig wird.
Und mit Gears und Sensitivität aus dem Weg,
los geht's mit dem eigentlichen Aim-Training.
Starten wir mit, Muskel-Memory zu bauen.
Das ist ein Witz, den man oft hören wird,
aber so viele Leute bauen Muskel-Memory durch Dumme-Luck.
Sie binden nur Spiele und denken, das bietet Muskel-Memory.
Du musst die Sachen richtig machen.
Es ist auch sehr möglich, dass du ein paar schlechte Habits bekommst,
indem du das so machst.
Habt ihr jemals die Leute gesehen,
die Muskel-Memory wie ein Pro machen?
Sie können Flick-Schotten usw.
und gewünschte Techniken usw.
Aber wenn du sie beobachtest,
ist es eigentlich relativ seltsam,
ob sie eigentlich nahe hinschneiden.
Ja, diese Leute versuchen Muskel-Memory zu bauen
durch Dumme-Luck.
Und sie schauen nur die Pros und was sie tun.
Und sie versuchen es zu emulieren.
Und sie fragen sich, was Muskel-Memory eigentlich ist.
Im Kontext des Spiels ist es so,
wie weit du deinen Maus bewegen musst,
um von wo dein Haar gerade ist,
zu wo dein Gegner ist.
Es verbindet auch Hand-Eye-Koordination.
Die Möglichkeit, etwas auf dem Bild zu sehen
und für deinen Arm und Rücken zu bewegen...
Zum Beispiel...
Erinnert ihr euch noch an Bad Company 2?
Dass es dann einen Shotgun-Bug gab?
Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz gutes Beispiel.
Du konntest, wenn du Waffen geswitcht hast,
die Shotgun schneller nachladen.
Solche Geschichten.
Und das ist was,
wenn man wirklich optimieren möchte,
sind das Sachen.
Da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Das ist erst mal nervig zu machen.
Aber irgendwann machst du ganz automatisch
Shotgun-Schuss...
Auf 1, 2 oder so.
Oder X. Was? X?
Das machst du automatisch.
Links rum.
Ganz automatisch.
Schießt Shotgun-Bam.
Das machst du ganz automatisch mit der Zeit.
Das muss man erst mal checken,
dass man das nicht richtig macht.
Und dann muss man sich erst mal
20 Stunden spielen,
dass man es halt automatisch macht.
Moment. Der Charakter Diamond sehe ich ja jetzt erst.
Diamond Omega Lul.
Das kann man machen, aber...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin...
Also ja, das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich bin kein
großartiger Aim-Map-Fan.
Das ist zum Aufwärmen, ist das ganz nice.
Aber da kann man genau so gut
theoretisch, keine Ahnung,
den Overwatch-Training-Kurs,
nicht den Overwatch-Training-Map oder so.
Also ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das
Also ich finde es auf jeden Fall fraglich,
ob das wirklich so viel bringt.
Richtig, richtig.
Du musst die Sachen richtig machen.
Das ist eigentlich das Schwierigste.
Das ist aber nicht nur in Games,
das ist überall so.
Deswegen sind Coaches auch so wichtig.
Weil wenn du selbst spielst,
du kriegst viele Sachen gar nicht mit.
Coaches ist jetzt übertrieben gesagt.
Es reicht schon,
wenn man sich einfach mal mit seinem Team
oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Leuten
einfach mal ein paar Replays anguckt.
Das macht einen riesen Unterschied.
Übrigens, Overwatch hat jetzt auch
einen Replay-Modus seit 3 Jahren.
Und dann musst du das richtig machen.
Für dieses Übungsprozess
benutze ich den Spidershot-Mode,
setzter Präzision.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist alles, was du tun musst.
So langsam wie du willst,
gehst du von einem Ziel
zum nächsten Ziel, zum nächsten Ziel.
Keine Sorge über die Geschwindigkeit.
Keine Sorge über den Schuss, den du am Ende bekommst.
Versuche nicht, den Maus über den Ziel zu bewegen
oder kurz zu stoppen.
Du willst zu dem Punkt kommen, wo du einen Ziel siehst
und du kannst dich mit Sicherheit
den Crosshair zu deinem Ziel bewegen
und dann...
Also ja, wenn du jetzt der
krasse Sniper-Dude bist,
ist es natürlich schon geil, wenn du um die Ecke springen kannst,
irgendwie flickst in die Richtung
und triffst den. Aber wenn du,
sag mal so, wenn du sowas spielst wie
Battlefield
oder so spielst oder irgendwie,
wahrscheinlich ist es bei Apex ähnlich,
da hast du viele automatische
Waffen und man
profitiert oftmals auch davon,
dass man die bessere Übersicht hat
und bessere Movement hat, durch ein bisschen
höhere Sensitivity, als dass man jetzt
jedes Mal seinen Flick trifft.
Also, es ist bei automatischen Waffen jetzt
nicht so extrem wild,
ob du...
Also, du musst schon dein Ziel treffen,
aber du musst in diesen Games
keine Flick-Headshots
machen, großartig.
Also, es kommt auch ein bisschen auf das Game an.
Das in Battlefield zum Beispiel
ist es ziemlich wurscht, oder in
den älteren Battlefield ist es ziemlich wurscht, ob man jetzt
irgendwie hier drauf,
da so instant auf jeden Pixel flicken kann
oder ob man in die schneller
sich drehen kann, sehen kann und
hier irgendwie wackel, wackel, wackel
draufsprayt auf den Gegner.
Das geht in Battlefield genauso.
Wahrscheinlich spielst du Battlefield sogar besser,
wenn du schnellere Sensitivity hast
und quasi den Gegner hier irgendwie in die Richtung
sprayst.
Außer du schneiberst.
Genji Mode.
Genji Mode,
ist das dann der Modus, wo man sich
Und du kannst auch...
...dass du deine Waffen wechseln kannst und so weiter.
Diese Features sind alle ziemlich cool, aber...
...in dem Mercy Mode gesagt... Es gibt... Moment, ich verstehe das richtig...
Es gibt... eine... Mercy Training Map?
Und ein Mercy-Training-Map?
Aber ehrlich gesagt, würde ich nur zu den mehr generisierten Übungen anstecken.
Persönlich finde ich den Spidershot und den Micro-Shot die wichtigsten.
Der Micro-Shot ist eigentlich ein wirklich guter zu probieren, weil, obwohl der Spidershot
für größere Bewegungen nutzt, mehr oft als nicht, wenn dein Spielsinn gut ist, weißt du
wahrscheinlich nicht genau, wo ein Gegner herkommen könnte, aufgrund der Mathe-Knowledge, Sound-Qs
und so weiter.
Also, die Chancen sind, dass dein Haar schon ziemlich nahe sein wird, wo sie herkommen.
Und für das...
Ich finde es ja toll, dass er genau das Gleiche sagt.
Also, wenn er auf die Idee kommt, nicht unabhängig voneinander auf die Idee kommen, werden wahrscheinlich
auch noch deutlich mehr Leute davon auf die Idee gekommen sein, dass das eben einfach
die richtige Variante ist.
Map-Kenntnis.
Reason.
Training small flicks ist wirklich nützlich.
Also, das ist, wie du Muskel-Memory trainierst, aber was sind noch ein paar andere Dinge, die
du...
Ich gib's doch, ey.
Das ist ja schon eine ganze Weile.
Schon 35 Jahre lang.
Let's take a look at aiming techniques.
So, what we've been working on so far is basically drag and flick shooting, which honestly,
while the execution is slightly different, they're basically the same thing, just at different
speeds.
And a huge amount of aiming will be done using these techniques, particularly with semi-automatic
weapons.
However, with fully automatic and beam weapons, you'll also want to learn a little bit about
tracking.
The good thing with tracking is the actual technique is basically the same as drag aiming,
but the execution is almost entirely prediction.
When you track an enemy smoothly, you're actually predicting their movement, not reacting
to it.
Otherwise, you'd constantly be behind where they actually are.
So if your flick aim is good, but your tracking is bad, chances are, it's not an aim issue,
it's a prediction issue.
And the only way you're going to improve that is to actually think less about your aim
and more about what movement your opponent might make next.
There is a workaround, however.
So let's quickly take a look at a relatively new technique called micro-flicking.
This is a technique that was popularized by a few Korean Overwatch players.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber die spielen mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so.
Das war diese Geschichte hier.
Ich glaube, das macht keiner mehr so.
Technique that takes all the prediction work out of tracking someone, and it's really quite
simple.
Basically, instead of smoothly tracking someone, you make a series of small corrections as
your opponent.
Na, NaNoHana heißt nicht mal NaNoHana.
NaNoHana ist jetzt glaube ich Flower oder so.
Der hat sich irgendwie dreimal umbenannt.
Depending on the game and the weapon you're using, it's often accompanied by tap-shooting
too.
So instead of just holding left-click and emptying your clip as fast as possible, you shoot
in bursts every time you make those tiny corrections.
This is actually a very useful technique for Apex Legends, where time to kill is long
and damage- Also außerdem gerade Overwatch da als Beispiel
zu nehmen ist eh nicht so das sinnvollste.
Also du hast in Overwatch selbstverständlich Helden, wo das nicht so einfach ist, aber
Overwatch ist jetzt bei weitem nicht das Click-and-Shoot-100%-Aiming-Game.
...per clip is relatively small.
Even though it might take longer to empty your clip, by using this technique, your accuracy
will most likely be higher.
So your chances of one-clipping someone can improve a lot by micro-flicking.
Smooth tracking in a perfect world looks a lot nicer.
And it can be more effective.
But the more skilled your opponents, the harder they'll be to track.
So micro-flicking can be a really useful technique to learn.
One other thing to quickly mention is projectile aim.
This applies to a bunch of Overwatch characters, and a ton of games only have projectile weapons,
including Apex Legends and Fortnite.
Your actual mechanical aim techniques remain the same whether you're using projectiles
or hitscan weapons.
But with projectiles, there's a focus on movement prediction.
You have to predict-
Ihr müsst euch mal, also was richtig gut ist, ihr müsst euch mal die älteren, wenn
ihr Overwatch spielt, guckt euch mal an, als Seagull gespielt hat, als Mei noch langsame
Projektile hat.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie der die Dinger so gut getroffen hat.
Das ist mir komplett unbegreiflich.
Die Dinger waren ja mal halb so schnell, die Eisprojektile früher.
Und der hat da die Headshots rausgehauen ohne Ende.
Zockt noch Overwatch, oder?
Ich hab letztens mal wieder PTR gespielt ein bisschen.
Stufe 1, aber POC.
Dankeschön, nice.
Du wirst bei Pharah deine Projektile eigentlich so gut wie immer flicken, vor allem wenn du
nah am Gegner dran bist.
Also ich kenn kaum einen Pharah-Spieler, der so macht.
Puff.
Die machen alle so, die fliegen alle so.
Fliege, fliege, fliege, fliege, puff.
Puff, puff.
ist, dass du nicht darüber nachdenken musst, wenn du in ein Spiel kommst.
Und wenn du alles machst, um deinen Ziel zu verbessern,
wirst du ein ziemlich lächerlicher Spieler werden.
Also, ein weiterer wichtiger Teil deines Trainings ist
der Todesmatch.
Viele, viele Todesmatch.
Okay, also wenn es jetzt rein um Overwatch geht, ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt, vor allem zum Warmspielen, aber das Problem ist einfach, dass das Deathmatch mit dem normalen Ablauf vom Game nichts zu tun hat.
Und du kannst halt Deathmatch übelst schießen, ne?
Spielst du was wie Roadhog oder was gibt es da sonst auch so OP-mäßiges? Roadhog, McCree, gibts übelste OP-Dinger in Deathmatch.
Du bist gegen echte Spieler, du hast wenig zu wenig Ablaufzeit, wenn du sterbst, und weil du das machst, kannst du deine Zeit maximieren, wenn du...
Man muss es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben, also die meisten Overwatch-Helden sind jetzt nicht so kompliziert zu spielen.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, ja, beispielsweise Ana, Ana ist übelst schwierig, oder sag mal so, auch Widow und Soldier oder Hanzo effektiv zu spielen.
Das ist nicht ohne, vor allem bei den Helden, wo es auf gutes Aiming ankommt, aber ich würde nie so weit gehen und würde das reine Shooter-Gameplay von Overwatch jetzt gleichsetzen mit CSGO zum Beispiel.
Weil bei CSGO ist deutlich mehr reine Shooter-Mechanics als das Overwatch ist.
Ja, es war schön, sie haben es angeschossen mit der Rakete.
Das ist übrigens eine Sache, die man auch in fast jedem Game lernen muss, wann man disengaged ist.
In dem Fall hätte man einfach ausweichen können, weiter schießen können, aber das heißt in Battlefield auch, wenn der Gegner die bessere Pose hat, bringt es nichts, da irgendwie versuchen, den Lucky zu killen, das ist viel besser, man geht in Deckung und umläuft den oder sowas.
Ich finde es ja toll, dass er die ganze Zeit über Aim erzählt und nichts davon macht.
Ich finde es toll, dass er die ganze Zeit über Aim erzählt und nichts davon macht.
Ich finde das Video gut, das ist im Prinzip genau das, was ich zu diesem Thema auch sagen würde.